Like, everyone can hear you.
Yeah.
Well, technically, sort of.
Sort of.
What about you?
I'm not about you.
Yeah, whenever we do, whenever I do collabs, I just go
straight into no waiting room.
It was quiet.
Oh, I'm going to talk into the microphone really close.
Okay.
If you hit escape, it says color, and you can change your
character's color.
But I know you guys are all green.
Wait, why are you eating green?
Oh my god.
Oh, no.
I can do another one now.
No, no, I deserve green.
Wait, we can have different colors?
Oh, wait, what color am I?
What's my color?
I'm green.
You are red right now, Doki.
I'm red.
Oh, wait, that fits me.
Okay, I'm giving I'm trying to give you guys, I want to give
you guys little hats.
Give me a sec.
I'm putting little hats on us right now.
Is my mic really quiet though?
Let me know if I'm like, you know, you're mostly okay.
And I can also turn you up, so it's fine.
Turned you up a little bit.
Well, I'm putting little hats on us.
Just tiny little hats.
There we go.
Mimi, could you say something so I can chest your audio?
Hello, yep, yep, yep.
Okay, okay, I can go.
Yeah, I think everybody needs to be turned up.
I appreciate it.
We don't have our magic wands yet.
No, not tongue.
I feel like...
I'm gonna be surprised if it registers any of us.
But I don't know why it's registering Spanish.
Hola.
La biblioteca.
I don't know.
I'm gonna switch over if you guys are okay.
Okay, me too.
Me.
I...
Wait, where's the magic...
There's like magic wines here.
There's no privacy here, man.
Fireballs!
Oh!
Hi!
How do I get my magic wine out?
They're not...
Look here.
It's not a dream.
Yeah.
Oh, here you go.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, but if we were all on YouTube, nobody would have seen
it.
Fireball.
Wind magic.
Wind.
They can just, you know, figure that there was probably
something wrong.
Wait.
Up dog.
And it, like, worked on you.
What?
It's called...
Watch this!
Tempest!
Boom!
It's up here.
There's like wands here.
Free wands.
Yeah, yeah.
Look, watch this.
Oh, he got one.
Up dog!
Woo!
Yeah.
It's my new magic spell, up dog.
How do you get a stick from the tree?
Oh, I broke up.
I think we took all this.
Oh, there should be one that's broke.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There should be more.
sticks, right?
Oh, you can bump...
Cute!
Uppies!
Contract, explode enemies with piss.
Look at that!
Mimi can't afford a magic wand!
If it's magical piss, it is.
Oh, wait.
Are these like our con... Oh, are these our goals?
Because it's like a dungeon, right?
Maybe they're like more cooperative than a duel.
Yeah, it's like a dungeon crawler type deal.
Oh, thank God.
I wasn't looking forward to getting, like, bullied again.
I mean, there is friendly fire.
Like, Tempest.
Okay.
Tempest.
Oh, shit.
Arrow.
Tempest.
Aerial.
Updang.
Oh, I'm flying.
Oh, you can't, there is fall damage, guys.
Everybody, there is fall damage.
Oh, wait.
You can get, like, prettier wands.
You can get, like, special wands here later on.
Ooh, a mystery egg.
I want a mystery egg.
Wait, there's a bottled fairy.
We can eat it.
We can eat the fairy.
What if the mystery egg is a cute pet?
Oh, yeah, that's true.
What if we can kill him and take his stuff?
There's four of...
There's five of us and one of him.
Well, four of us with wands.
Four of us and all we can really do is say, up dog, and...
to be errors like okay oh okay so like i i will have to say
this hub is not very intuitive because like how the do we
start this game i think it has something to do with this
wait look what i can do oh oh i'm did you kick it no i think
i think your your ass was too fat i think my barrel
Oh, chat says the...
You hear that?
That's amazing.
Oh, my God.
That's beautiful.
Wait, play us a song.
I...
Wait, watch this.
Oh.
What are you doing?
Oh, look.
can lift dokey all right let's go yeah i can be in a
backpack now i can get carried yeah wait can you actually no
you oh wait wait minute press b but now i don't have one so
how about we become the musicians all the bars wait you guys
guys press b press b
That's what V does.
So apparently...
Oh yeah, sound guy.
Is everybody okay or do you want me to adjust?
How the fuck are you holding that frog?
I picked it up off the floor.
Also, you got...
Sound guy.
You can adjust it via individual.
Alright, so apparently...
my my chat says that oh god oh oh where are we going this
might be a good thing all right teleporting we're
teleporting we're going wait did anyone looked at the
contracts i didn't oh
everyone's a bit quiet wait a sound guy alive my frog came
with me oh well our wands came with us too all right i'll
put everybody up oh nice
kind of smelly playing Song of your mom.
Oh, shit.
Everyone, how did you know?
But I want to see you.
Can I be...
What are we doing in this game?
Oh, I'm blue now?
We have to get quota.
Yeah, yeah, but like...
I didn't even...
I didn't read our job description.
Did anyone read what our contract wanted us to do?
We have to explode.
That's fine with piss and steal at least two gold.
Okay, steal...
No!
I've lost 40 feet!
Alright, that's it.
Who did that?
Tempest.
That's right!
Who did that?
Alright, I'll grab...
Oh, it's like repo.
Oh, you get money by breaking things.
You get money by breaking things.
Oh, nice.
I have...
Nice.
Alright, so we're Zelda-ing it.
Yeah, if you have sold those boxes, it seems to do things.
Arrow.
Oh, oh, oh, who did that?
Who did that?
Wow, who did that?
I'm going up the stairs up here.
Guys, I'm going up the stairs too.
It's like a reverse.
Oh, you fucked yourself over.
Yeah, I feel like it will go forward.
Oh, wait, we only have 10 minutes.
Tempest.
There's a timer.
Oh, shit.
okay so are you supposed to break things friendly fired yeah
you're supposed to break things for money we have to get 900
coins with piss you have to just real tempest and it'll work
yeah we need a different one maybe to break things with piss
i think like i yeah but we need to make money to to get
money arrow look at this guys look at this watch this what
i'm gonna use my brilliant up dog you're so smart Oh!
Up dog!
Is there something up here?
I'm gonna throw this...
Okay, I didn't make it, guys.
Oh.
Wait, you got a candle?
Wait, how is stuffy gonna get down from here?
What?
Guys, there's a thing running around.
What do you mean?
There's a guy in there.
Wait, wait, you have the candle.
You can't see any...
Are you sure, man?
I don't see nobody.
Yeah.
You know what they say.
The boy who cried wolf.
green man there was a green someone are you sure it's not
you you're technically green are you sure you didn't see a
mirror man you know what they say the boy who cried wolf
well you all regret it when he comes back when he comes back
when he gets you oh look there's a wizard man area a wizard
man look look at him he must be the the headmaster oh i feel
so chaotic I accidentally burnt it.
Yeah, it caught on fire.
I didn't even touch it.
I mean, I did touch it.
That's all I did.
You got so much money from that.
We should just burn it.
Oh, come on.
Let's go.
Wait, how did you burn?
Oh, did you touch it with your candle?
Our sound guy, I helped everybody.
Wait, do we go up or down?
Guys, let's split.
Oh, shit.
Warp to extraction.
Interesting.
Oh?
Oh, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
Is that the green man?
The green man?
There was something up there.
See?
Where?
Somebody's...
I thought it looked like a frog.
Somebody is...
Gee, I told you!
Wait, what are these?
Oh, look!
There's something there!
Oh, there's something there!
Arrow!
We do not die!
Oh!
Oh no!
Wait, wait, no, no!
I'm one of you!
Don't hurt me!
It's me!
Tokey bird!
would you love me if i was a if i was a worm i hate that i
don't yeah i don't know how it happened i just that's
awesome that was disgusting i thought i thought you were
coming to murder me Oh, he's...
Oh, it's a goblin!
Oh, he's still there!
I found him!
I told you!
You were about to execute us all!
Holy shit!
Are you calling your people?
Oh, yeah, by the way, Min, there's no He's at the bottom of
the stairs!
There's no fall damage, so we can jump down if we have to.
Oh, there's none?
Yeah, there's no, yeah.
If he crumbs up, if he comes up.
If he crumbs up?
Yeah.
Who is in here destroying everything?
I don't know.
Whoa.
I'm glad I got this.
Oh, yeah.
Summon your summoning song.
Oh, my God.
I think we need to sacrifice someone.
Oh, the green man.
We should bring the green man over.
Oh, yeah, I killed the green man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, my candle went out.
Um.
spooky that is a little spooky it'll be a pretty awkward if
someone shouted a spell right now in the middle of
everything oh that was an accident actually yeah yeah i was
just doing this wait a camera selfie cam wait a selfie
camera wait how do you do that my middle mouse button does
Wait, what?
Oh!
Whoa!
Wait, you're right!
Wait!
Guys, we have five and a half minutes left.
Guys, how come...
I count four of us.
We're missing one person in this group.
Life is probably working and doing it all.
Oh, that's true.
She's actually...
She's actually doing our work for us.
Wait, it says minuses.
I think she actually is.
She's like that one person in the group project that does
all our work and we're just chilling.
in the corridor.
We're doing research.
Hi.
I was here.
All right.
Oh, I- Wait, you killed- Wait, the green man is friendly.
Did you see that?
Yeah, he's pretty chill.
He simply doesn't seem to like us.
Uh, Tempest.
Aerial.
Tempest.
Nice.
I got us $2.
Two whole dollars.
Oh, so sound guys.
Everybody okay now?
Oh, that's good.
The guy was trying to sell that for four gold or something.
The mystery egg.
Look, I found Golem Goonads.
Oh.
Did you stash that?
Did you steal my Goonads?
Who did that?
What the fuck?
Who stole the balls?
Wait.
Can we unify our magical power and cast arrow on this one?
Oh, wait, yeah, yeah.
I did already hit it once.
Let's do a countdown.
Okay, okay.
Okay, three, two, one.
Arrow!
Oh.
Surprise!
He like nearly slammed dunked onto it.
You can get 10 points for hitting it once.
All right, Tempest.
Oh, the covers doesn't destroy itself.
of are so spooky wait uh aerial i got us two dollars i feel
like temp arrow is such a shitty spell it barely gives us
wait guys
got fairy wings whoa is everybody okay is this guy evil no
he's a nice guy oh he's not nice he's He's not nice!
He's not nice!
Um, there's a bomb?
Yeah, yeah, I felt... Yeah, he's...
He might not be a good guy.
Alright.
Um, he has a bomb, guys.
Tempest!
Where's my wand?
Oh, there it is.
Uh, Ariel.
I can't even kill her.
I'll light him on fire.
Wait, let me test on you.
Oh, wait, are you gonna do the Metal Gear strat?
Sorry to me.
I saw you were donkey.
Oh, I see how it is.
You don't you can't Wow can't even recognize colors Okay, it
was really bright.
Okay.
Area Well can't even recognize your fellow green.
You miss every time.
No, no, no, I wasn't planning on aiming anything Nice.
I think I think the goblin dude just threw a bomb at me yeah
no he's not a nice guy he's not a very nice guy yeah he's
quite rude he's he's alone he's a little mean not gonna lie
sound effects up is it this sound effects it's really hard
to see anything it is we definitely need light i feel like
we can get like fire ones later though we have one minute to
get 90 gold guys how do we get home
There's no fall damage, so you'll be fine.
Wait.
Nibby?
What happened?
What happened to her?
I don't know.
She just said I'll go down and then...
What did you...
You committed a crime, man.
I didn't do it.
You were the last person next to her.
Don't worry.
I'll hide the evidence.
I'll hide the...
Don't worry.
Oh, she, oh, that's why she jumped down and then reappeared
there.
Oh, I think that pit was a bottomless pit.
I think so.
It's okay.
Well, Mimi, we're about to die anyway.
No, no, no, no.
We got this.
We have one minute to get 90 dollars.
Extract.
Okay, we have, we still need 90 dollars, Mint.
Are you extracting right now?
I don't know what that means.
he's going back home oh oh i didn't realize that's what that
was okay so what are we gonna do with the body can we burn
it oh no 30 minutes what is this oh i'm pondering yeah we're
pondering the orb wait what did we just leave can we leave
we would wait extract extract for real yeah okay not all all
wait but we have to wait for everybody but they don't know
we're here I think we might, I think we're, we lost,
goodbye.
Goodbye!
Oh, extract anyone, yes, yes, wait, I extracted anyway.
Wait, what does the ghost approaches mean?
It's okay, we're fine, we'll live though.
It's okay, we'll be alive.
Oh, okay, I made it.
We made it.
We made it!
Yay, did you guys lose, too?
Three players missed extraction.
I mean by a ghost I don't think we made it we lost well I
mean it's just 300 yeah it's just 306 gold we did we did I
think like we'll be fine we'll be fine what did the ghost
look like something else now oh we only have 22 personal
gold well that's beans wait what you mean the cool stuff
that I got wait do I get a wait that means like the company
takes 90 we only earn like five percent in the company ticks
95 i think they might have docked our earnings wait yeah but
22 of each we had it's at 706 in the end how do you cast a
spell oh here but yeah i think i think it's it might be that
anything we get over is spendable it's like i think it's
like lethal company where we have three nights to hit the
close-up wow guys it really does feel like corp we're
working in a black company right now yeah oh moon like oh
yeah that's that's fair we maybe we earn gold based on our
chaos because yeah we're not i have breaking things we're
getting chaos i have how do i how do i grab the what how do
i get rid of the fish stash the gonads oh i stashed it how
do i yeah how do i access the stash items maybe you can
maybe you can give that man your balls uh excuse me Excuse
me?
Is that...
That seems like an HR complaint.
Wait, how do we...
I don't know if you can sell things.
How...
Yeah, I have a fairy.
It's a dragon bone.
I mean, you could actually buy a dragon bone or an amber.
Wait, you can actually purchase the golem go nuts.
He's got them here unless you just sold them.
Wait, I thought you were joking.
They're actually...
No, they're not real.
Yeah.
Explode slime.
It was kind of hard to see in the game.
Wait, chat, how do we...
What do we do with...
chat how do we get the items that we stashed because i have
the gonads and and fairy wings if you didn't if you didn't
make it out you're not getting them i did i did make it out
i extracted but yeah one of us did yeah i did yeah me and
memory extracted we're at the orb and then we saw ghosts
disappearing and then we pieced out we're like goodbye yeah
all of the all of the uh the goblin guys they also go aggro
when you uh when you die oh and so they they pulled out
They're like, they kind of turned around, looked at me,
went, and then they're like, it's time.
This is terrifying.
Peace is the ceasefire is over.
Let's go again.
Wait, wait, I'm gonna grab.
Actually, yeah.
I'll just use my win one.
I'm ready.
I still- I still don't know how to- Wait, where is Mint?
Yeah.
Where's Mint and Snuffy?
Alright, we're extracting guys.
We're going in on another job.
Okay, wait.
I still don't know how to get my inventory stuff out.
I stash two things.
It doesn't say.
Task list.
Oh, wait.
Watch this.
Oh.
Press T, guys.
Hold T, hold T.
Oh.
Yeah,
let's go, Ron.
Good job.
You.
What's this?
Guys, we have to think on what spell keys.
We are the wizards.
Yell.
Yell out the spell.
I feel that.
Yell a real loud.
Tebulous.
Tempest!
Oh my god, I will use...
Okay, I'm gonna start it.
I'm gonna start it.
I want to see what other magics we can do.
I think we did great.
Yeah, yeah, I think we did.
Yeah, yeah, I think we're doing a good job, guys.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think we're doing our money.
I don't know.
I just spent some on a torch so that we could see.
I have...
I have a panel.
wait wait i think we do i have 12 left hold on wait i have
12 left who spent my fucking savings oh it is a collective
money oh my god sorry oh magic wait what's this phoenix
brother arrow oh my god oh my god oh my god oh it's all
going right i mean what's arrow yeah arrow I'm going left.
I'm going up.
I'm going high ground.
That's where they stash all their jewelry.
Wait, who's that?
Oh wait, that's Snuffy.
I was like, wait, who's that imposter?
I've never seen this wizard before my life.
Arrow.
Nice.
Wait, we're already almost at 900.
Wait, how the fuck did we make 700 in the...
instantly?
arrow arrow we just destroy stuff we just kind of yeah it's
it's anti-repo anti-repo you destroy everything yeah oh
what's that guy arrow arrow arrow tempus i'm gonna beat him
up yeah we're making cash fast do i have a oh do you have a
torch how do i sit on fire hold on hold on How do I do it?
Because we get money if we set it on fire.
I don't know.
I'm trying to set it on fire right now.
Hold on.
Let me try and use this.
Oh!
Okay, but oh, oh yeah, we got money, eh?
You worked for us.
See things are good.
Wait, did you kill that guy?
Oh, wait, no.
Tempest.
Wait, can I set him on fire?
Error!
Oh, he's throwing bombs!
Oh my god.
Wait, he's not taking damage.
She's not taking damage.
Tempest!
Oh, he is?
No, he is taking damage.
Oh, yeah, he is.
Oh, okay.
what was what was bombs on him wait can i set him on five
it's okay he can't hurt us until until it's 10 minutes arrow
well he's gone he's trying to hurt us though yeah but he but
apparently lime was said by a 10 minute mark he they bring
out the swords i think there's some yeah yeah nice but he's
not i took i took damage though arrow okay i'm okay i'm okay
i'm okay I'm okay.
Arrow.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Not again!
Oh, shit.
I got my face.
Um.
She's dead.
Mitt?
That's two deaths.
I wasn't dead.
Mitt.
That's two deaths.
It's very weird that every time I came over.
Look at her.
Look at her go.
Every time I walk over here, a dead body appears next to
you, Mitt.
That's a little...
No, she's alive.
She's alive.
Snuffy, if you are alive, say arrow.
Do you see what she's doing right now?
Yeah, yeah, what's she doing?
What is she doing?
Breaking it down.
Are we going to weaken at Bernie's list right now?
I'm not even holding her.
Are you?
Wait, wait, wait.
that's okay all right oh yeah i'll be the you'll be the
voice i'll be the i'll be the holder it's like it's karma
we're gonna weekend at snuffies this i didn't do any oh yeah
yeah i i'm a raccoon is that all you is that all she is
she's just a raccoon that's all she is I'm a sexy raccoon.
Oh, what just happened?
Oh, what does that mean?
I don't know.
We stepped into some little circle.
There's orbs.
Oh, arrow.
Wait, updog.
Oh, my God.
If stuffy wasn't live, she would know what to do.
No, she wouldn't.
And she doesn't.
And she would.
Wait, I got one of them.
Wait, updog this.
Arrow.
No.
This!
Do you see the orb?
Grab the orb!
Oh my God!
I think that's what!
We can't get out!
Oh my God!
We're gonna die!
Up dog!
There's literally no orb!
It is!
I see it's right here!
Oh!
Then you get it!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait!
No, no, no!
Okay, do you see these?
I see them!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, I think we're gonna be...
Okay, up dog.
Up dog.
dog all right got another one yes um okay okay i found
another one i found another one i don't have up dog cool
down i need up dog cool down oh my god up dog hold on where
is it where is it i see i see i see i got it oh there's one
there's one there's one up here i think that's last one
that's last one no there's four out of seven oh no man if
only we had a third player here right now if only if only
someone I wasn't if only someone didn't kill our third
player I don't think yeah I don't think we're gonna see her
acting like this on your screen or she's just dead like
that's all I see it's all I see yay
yeah oh yeah we have to oh no they're always in a different
place she's killing me though she's killing me the ghost the
ghost of the past up dog
all right i got to oh my god what where the hell oh
Me!
That is!
Arrow!
Oh, it's like a mimic.
It is a mimic!
I don't think we should do this quest.
I think we should find the extraction.
I am not okay right now.
Wait, where is the mimic?
Where is she?
Where's what?
Where's the mimic?
Oh, it went over here.
Yeah, no, no, do not get, don't get near it.
It's gonna...
I just can't stop watching Snuffy.
What is she doing on your screen?
She's currently under the ground.
She's really glitching out like crazy.
Oh, no.
But then to get close to her, she like hurts me because
she's like a weapon.
Get away from me!
Oh my god!
Oh, hello!
So...
Snuffy...
Oh, you guys wanna help us with this?
Wait, this would be great!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
happened to snuffy so what happened was i walked over and
the dead snuffy was next to men which was pretty suspicious
because that's two out of two of dead bodies next to men
guys we gotta give her a proper burial i'll give her a
proper burial everyone help us with this quest we gotta look
we're gonna press this thing let's all dance around the body
the honor no no really hurt she doesn't hurt me though wait
we can use her yes the goblin use it on the goblin yeah yes
doesn't hurt me because i didn't commit any crime also be
also be careful because uh men and i encountered a mimic and
we don't know where he went and he i know where he went it's
literally right here where is he I don't see him.
Right here.
Where?
I'm dead.
Died the tornado.
Oh.
Is that it?
Is that karma right there?
Ariel.
Arrow.
Oh, I don't think she's alive no more Okay, so should we
leave we should leave we should really we should leave okay
Don't be the fucking doors locked.
No, no, no, no, no, okay, basically no, no, no, okay, so you
guys don't worry Don't we we were then we're there's a timer
here.
You see that little timer there the moment that timer ends
we're freed and nothing bad will happen to us Okay Unless we
get hit by the thrashing Oh no.
Oh no.
Oh hey look, the door's open.
All right, let's go.
Let's leave.
That is a bad room.
We did live fully left.
Oh my god, you fully booked it.
Okay, so Snuffy's body is right over there next to Wait,
wait, no, okay, I can't touch Snuffy.
She almost killed me.
I got I got meant
I don't know she works for me Okay, I grabbed stuffy Don't
worry.
I'm the only one she does in her cuz she knows I didn't
commit a crime She's like stuck oh there I got it
I am blessed.
Wait, where did Lyme go?
Oh.
Why did I just got a bomb?
That's not
good.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, kill him.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Where did it come from?
It's the guy with the sword.
Did you get killed?
I got it.
I got killed by the bomb.
By the fucking bomb.
We got caught by a bomb.
A bomb!
Start the extraction!
Run!
No, it's time, it's time, so the moment they get hit.
We thought it was safety, it was not safety.
What do we do?
I thought it was- Wait, is that not the extraction?
I don't know where she found it, oh.
Wait, this is the wrong way, I think.
Oh, they're lost.
The ghost is here.
Oh, the ghost is here.
Oh, the ghost approaches.
The ghost...
I think...
I think me...
Me, you, and stuffy threw a little bit by being stuck in
that room.
Oh, hey!
She seems pretty!
Oh!
Oh dear.
Oh.
No way.
It's okay.
We still have...
It's fine on night, guys.
It's fine on night.
Guys, it's fine on night.
It'll be fine.
That was crazy.
I am so sorry for my people.
I thought it was an extraction because I didn't read it, but
no, it worked us straight into a gigantic suit of fucking
armor.
wait no stuffy you're being weird oh sorry sorry it's
stuffy's body again i know i did it was how it should be i
had so much i had so much to give so much money i don't know
the profits they would have been incredible we're gonna make
so much money guys it's okay we definitely got it this time
oh my god my leg it's all right someone start the extraction
i'll just be lying here i'm just gonna lie down here we got
this guys wait oh wait hold on i need my i need i can i
believe in us we're grabbing one six five four three two one
i want another torch i want i want to burn i'm depressed
from my crippling debt guys It's so realistic.
Guys, we're in crippling debt.
What's the point?
What's the point if we're just gonna lose money anyway?
Honestly, I feel very lonely for you.
What's the point, Nimi?
What's the point?
Life is meaningless.
We're in debt.
We just wake up.
We had minus 25!
oh well that's not right that's not right all right tempest
tempest all right tempest is stronger i don't actually i'm
already tired of a grind i know my nine to five off my nine
to five wizard job yeah it's my baby my baby egg or baby egg
yeah i still don't even know, I still don't know where the
stash items go.
Ario.
Oh, is the extraction just where we came from?
No, no, the extraction is where we have to go where it takes
us back to the main base.
There's nothing here.
It's a dead end.
I don't believe you.
Oh, that's just one of us.
It was just really scary.
Who is it a deadhead?
You just got to jump.
You just got to parkour, man.
I didn't even see that part You didn't even have to jump
Yeah, I take the jump Oh, okay Oh, hey, there's a candle
Nice Alright Don't worry, I can light us the way now It also
is fall damage in this game Are you sure?
I didn't take fall damage Try it here I definitely did Wait,
I'll try Oh, not here though Yeah, see Arrow I thought I
could like cast my spell Destroy Destroy air oh it's magic
tempest is ever are you okay down there yeah i come down i'm
gonna take the stairs all right so the stairs what the i
don't have to do this i just don't remember i mean it's
easier it's more convenient yeah for sure yes oh it's a
demon room whoa wait what oh oh it's fine oh wait it was it
was It was the extraction room, but...
This is the extraction room?
It was.
This is where we extracted first, remember?
I remember, actually.
I actually don't either.
I just made that up.
I was hoping you could...
Tempest.
Wait,
I got Bacillus Heart!
Look!
Look at this.
What is that?
It has...
It's like...
It's for somebody's surgery.
Yeah!
There's someone...
I think it must have been Lamo.
I'm pretty sure.
She's the most competent player on our team.
I think we all sing.
I'm just going to play with Lamo.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Aero.
What's this?
Wait, no, this is the extraction room.
Is this the extraction room?
Aero.
No, it's not.
There's nothing to extract.
i thought this was the one we know there's a giant crystal
i'm climbing up i'm grabbing oh money money's always good
wait i'm gonna arrow oh i'm stashing this i still don't know
what stashing does but i don't know either maybe it shows up
after the day is over maybe it's so hard to see this oh wait
there's a third floor oh yeah you got p on it that's one of
our contracts oh he's aggressive oh he's aggressive tempus
okay nice i'm on the third floor and i don't know how to get
down guys a little scary right now.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, I got it.
I figured it out.
Oh.
Well, I'll get into the tornado.
Oh, never mind.
I mean, your tornado's sort of like, you know, it wasn't me
and not me, you know, so...
That's true.
Should we find Limeo extract?
I'm pretty sure she can find her own extraction.
Can we extract?
I think we got it.
I think, honestly, I think the goal is we should figure out
where the extractions because there's a higher chance that
she'll...
live and we won't oh there's over here oh there she is this
arrow there's something super valuable up here arrow where
is it it's golden but i need to get up dog it oh the pot
yeah i'm waiting for my up dog oh i couldn't oh what is it
what did you get yeah yippie what is it oh and a chest oh
how do you
That did not sound like the scream of victory.
Wait, what was that?
Wait, Lymo's dead!
Wait, how did she die?
She just fell on me.
Wait, where's the gold?
Where's the gold?
She said there was a gold thing up there.
Do you see it?
She broke it, but it was like six.
And then she screamed.
Oh, oh shit!
It's okay, it's okay.
It's still five minutes left.
He doesn't, it's a ceasefire.
Okay, where are we going to keep distracting?
Oh my gosh, no, I thought.
Oh, okay, okay.
Eww.
This is the thing that...
Updog.
Lime we tried before, though.
Wait, where is it?
Updog.
Oh, I don't know.
I was dead.
Wait, I don't know how you guys got up there.
Oh, there it is.
Get up here, get up here.
Yeah, come on, come on, come on.
Let's see what happens.
Where's the first Lime was dead body?
Um...
Whoa.
I dropped it on you, guys.
well oh there's the ponder orb and then the extraction is
right here it's literally right here i guess we could we
could book it now wait wait do we have can we get do we need
more money i mean we're did a good job we're freaking rich
yeah yeah good job team good job see guys we don't need la
mood again to win a game see you know those like charts
where they're like la mood is yeah Lime was 99% of our
group.
Look at that.
We lived, though.
The 1% lived.
And there we go.
Arrow.
Tapus.
Oh.
That worked.
We made it.
We did.
So do you know what happened to me?
What happened?
found i found a chest and i said oh a chest and and the game
went tempest okay and blew me out of the window with my own
you friend whoa we're on ahead did we do a good job sir is
this our patron no he's our boss wow don't squish me we know
this is freaky i'm tiny oh Oh Yeah, he's watching us.
What's your quota?
We we made him eight nine hundred dollars and he gave us
twelve gold
Also chat is the voice okay.
Is there's a basement is the sound balance okay now It's so
real.
Oh my god, he does look like the Katamari guy doesn't he
chat does stuff stay because I sashed a bunch of things
leaves if I die.
Oh, I opened the basement.
Oh, sweet.
This is where we stash your stuff.
I hope forbidden magic lies beneath.
Oh, I think so, baby.
Oh, oh, that's where we stash.
Wait, I have, I have the basilis heart here.
I'm going to stash this then.
Study potions.
Oh, you can make potions.
Yeah.
There's a gold here.
Should we take the gold?
Healing potion, health boost.
substantial of this I guess so so we can make oh there's a
flight potion I found fairy wings for that yeah wait can I
buy a wand I promise I won't blow myself out the window guys
there's a froggy potion we can become frogs good I'm gonna
press F and then Q.
So if we take...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, then you stash it.
Yay.
Yeah, stash it.
Yeah, yeah, see, it shows up right here.
Oh, it showed up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, cool, okay.
I'm gonna grab one of the health potions.
We have 87 gold now.
We should treat ourselves to something.
Oh, my God.
We need a revive potion.
One of our quests is to burn things, so I think we should
all get torches.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
They're also, they're available for free in the castle
rooms.
I stole this one from a wall.
I don't know how to do this.
Phoenix Feather.
Oh, who's our cook?
Who's the cook in the team?
Snuffy loves doing magic spells.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's already, like, you know, brewing.
She's like a witch.
I'm surprised you don't have a, you don't have a witch
outfit.
I know you have a sorcerer.
I really do.
No, you have a sorcerer.
Wait, you're a wizard?
Wait, I'm, yeah.
Wait, I need some sort of purple balls.
What is this?
Are these the gonad?
What are these purple- I don't think we have the ingredient?
Purple blood.
What did you do?
You're nerdy?
What did you- What- Why do you sound like that, Lop?
What did you do?
I drank a potion!
What- what potion did you drink?
Oh my- I wanted a potion!
What potion did you make?
Nothing!
What did you have?
I gave you a floor potion.
Wait, was it a stamina one?
Don't drink flakes on the floor.
I literally said nerd potion and it was underneath the
cauldron, so I drank it.
The first rule, you never drink stuff on the floor.
Snubby, there are some gonads here.
Did you want them?
I don't know what they're for.
Is there more?
I've never seen before, some sort of purple mushroom or
something.
to find more we gotta go back to the kids i'm gonna go
upstairs wait there's a portal oh i'm outside now oh i'm
gonna treat myself who else is talking like oh hey oh did
you hear did you hear snuffy's nerd voice wait what oh i
can't hear you anymore oh hello hello hola i can i can hear
you i can What happened?
I got a new wand.
I got a wand.
Oh, yeah, yeah, use it.
Wait, okay, wait, hold on.
Oh, uh, uh, piss, yuck.
Ew, ew, what the heck?
Oh my god, how did you get that pissing wand?
You know what they're, you know what you're giving them.
You do know what you're giving them right now.
You know what kind of art is gonna come from this.
You fucking know what kind of art that we're gonna get from
this.
Yeah, yeah Here someone else can try it someone else can try
it.
I want to try it.
I want to try it Turn me into a fish turn me into oh What's
this?
I chew
Oh my god, fish.
Yeah, sickness.
Oh my god, you're a big fish
Piss ya!
Piss on the face!
What the fuck?
Well, you really, uh, really want I'll turn up the master.
Now you gotta pee on the, um, the slime.
Oh, yeah, it's true.
That's true.
All right.
Who wants the grotesque one?
Who else wants the grotesque one?
I don't want them.
Come on.
Let me look.
The blessed one.
Oh, what's that?
Swap.
Oh, it sounds cool down.
Thank you.
Whoa.
Where'd she go?
Oh, she over there.
Teleport's behind you.
Oh, no, she teleported.
Okay.
I just disappeared.
Don't worry.
This one is like teleporting and stuff.
guys oh i know everybody i am fish
we're ripping it we're ripping it this one does i'm the
noble seed you are a beautiful noble slightly stinky seed
yeah we'll save over the last one Yeah, yeah, yeah, we gotta
get that one the blessed one.
That's to be a heal one, right?
I got a torch.
So, hold on.
I'll take the piss one.
Okay, is anyone's... Is live sounding weird or is that just
my document?
Why did you automatically go...
Oh, I didn't do it!
I didn't do it!
Why do you automatically pee on me as the first person you
want to piss on?
Oh, yeah, yeah, you just didn't know.
He didn't know this.
When you gotta go, you gotta go, you know?
You gotta go, you gotta go.
You sound really sound like you're like doubled up Yeah, you
sound normal to me.
I think there's some glitches with the uh Maybe earlier doki
kind of sounded like she was in a box for me So I yeah,
yeah, I think maybe when we teleport we'll like fix itself.
Oh, yeah, you are you marking your territory with the piss?
Is that it?
I'm active.
Oh, if I say ew, then it just starts shooting out That's not
true.
That's not true
Or so is does everybody sound okay now chat don't forget we
got a piss on the slime we see oh yeah Yeah, yeah, we see a
slime.
Yeah, that will be my duty.
Yeah Make sure to drink drink enough water mate.
Make sure to drink enough water for it.
Oh, yeah, we gotta we gotta Reload you got reload.
Tempest Is there a one that lets me down your lots of fires?
I do Yes, I hope they weren't too quiet earlier.
Oh, fuck I hit my head.
God.
It's crazy The men are so hard
But yeah, guys, I hope they weren't too quiet earlier chat I
have something called astral eyes just let me see things
that are magical Oh, what does that do?
Honestly, I think all the ones are overrated compared to
just fucking getting things with a...
Wait, wait.
Can you turn?
Oh, we don't want to go in there.
Why?
Turn him into a fish.
Wait, he's kind of cool with the...
Or piss on him.
Oh, wait, what is it?
Wait, turn him...
Wait, see if you can turn him into a fish.
Turn him into a fish.
Fish, yuck.
Oh, I don't think that worked.
Wait, wait.
Piss on him.
Yuck You think he likes it?
I don't think he likes it
Tempest they tried to ward Tempest fish yuck Tempest oh my
god.
Oh my god Tempest is not working.
Oh there you go.
Oh my god.
Why does it go towards me?
Why didn't you go to Orgy?
There's an eyeball that shoots!
I'm okay.
Aerial.
Piss on it!
Sneeze on it!
Achoo!
Oh!
You sneeze on it!
Tempest!
Aerial!
Guys, he is...
Guys, why is he...
What?
How much HP does this man have?
Oh, no, I'm getting a little most, oh, I'm getting old.
Are we even damaging him?
I don't know.
He does have a lot of armor.
Oh.
Oh, it's okay.
We're so safe right now.
We don't even do anything.
I'm okay.
Juked.
Oh, my God.
There's two.
oh you guys are fighting for your oh oh everything is okay
yeah yeah you're playing an Elden Ring you can never escape
Elden Ring are you in here I'm above you oh area tempest
tempest every time I say tempest it thinks I'm saying tap
piss oh it worked now arrow all right there we go earning
money i think lamu is doing her job but we're getting
harassed by a man in armor oh hey arrow is everything okay
over there tempus
Here we go.
It's the only way.
It can't register my voice.
Up dog.
Okay.
I slowly go down.
Yeah!
Where is everybody?
Hello?
Oh no, I lost everyone.
Guys, I'm scared.
Where are my...
my fellow wizards hello
are you guys okay wait there's a frog down there okay i'm
going downstairs is that
there you go there you go there you go i gave you a speed
bus
God, okay, okay, okay, it's fine, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh, this is like a revive chamber.
Oh, I see, that's what it is.
Oh my God, oh my God, they can open doors.
okay guys guys i'm getting cat tempest tempest arrow oh my
god oh my god oh my god it's okay he doesn't know how to go
into the demon room the demon room i am safe i am safe in
the demon Oh hey guys Is the guy still alive?
Did Lyme live?
Oh my god the eye is back?
The eye is back?
Oh no not the eye!
Not the eye!
Oh it's a mimic!
Arrow!
He's got...
He's got fire?
You can revive people in this room.
Yeah yeah I noticed that.
Yeah I noticed you came back alive.
Oh.
It's okay if we stay here.
Wait.
Oh yeah, he can't come in here.
He can't come in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is our safe room.
Ah,
no!
Why do you?
Hippis.
Ah, let's keep ready.
Keep ready.
Don't
duck.
Look, look, look.
Oh my god, the health potion only gives you 10 HP.
What is the point?
All right, I think we gotta find the extraction.
oh wait that was the same frog i saw oh you came down here
and you chose to go back up no there was no there was a
mimic there was literally a mimic down here i'm gonna grab
that frog arrow all right tempest oh so he got oh plus 75 so
we might i think some someone's dead may have me perhaps i
don't think so tempest up arrow I don't think everyone
survived.
I have.
Why is this area so hard?
We did too good of...
Oh, run.
Run past it.
Run past him.
Wait, but where do we run to?
Arrow.
Guys, this is a dead end.
Oh, shit.
No, no, no.
There's a stairs.
There's stairs here.
We gotta move.
All right.
Where are we now?
Oh, oh guys!
I found it!
Oh, I found the porcelain throne!
Guys, guys!
Oh, oh!
Where's the extraction?
Oh my god, there's the slime.
Where is it?
Hello?
There's a slime here!
Man!
Man, you get pissed on, that's the way, who asked the, who
asked the one?
I can't hear you.
Wait, wait, hello?
Hello?
Hello.
No, don't you fucking know.
Are you really dokey?
Hola.
John, that's your dokey.
Up dog.
Okay.
What happened?
I can't hear you.
Hello.
Hola.
Bibliotheca.
I think Jimmy dies.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, come on, boy.
Yes, yeah, yeah.
Come here.
Yes!
I'm like that dog!
That dog!
What was... Chad, what's that dog's name?
I'm like that dog!
Not up dog, you know, that they were like, where did little
Billy fell in the well?
Are you telling me to follow you?
Are you... Come on, boy, jump if you're telling me to follow
you!
I'm... I'm Lassie!
Little Timmy fell down the well?
What's this?
Oh.
You think she understand?
This is a warp east!
I don't fucking know!
Warp east!
We're doing it, we're warping east.
Surely that's the right way.
Oh wait, we're back here.
Wait, what?
Where are we?
Oh, we're not gonna be able to head back home.
Oh No, wait This Oh, no Where are we?
This way, this way Wait, this way, we haven't gone this way
Oh shit Ziggy potion It has to be this way This has to be it
There's no other door Oh my god It has to be it Oh, it must
be up here.
Oh my god, nice.
Oh, oh.
Get it.
Activate it.
Yay.
The last, like, I'm like, last scene.
It's like, where is the, where did little Timmy jump in the
well?
Where, where is little Timmy?
I couldn't hear you.
Yeah.
All things considered, I think we lost.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we got to keep our money.
We did lose all our money.
We did it in the end.
I got your wand, but I couldn't get to the extraction.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, no, that's okay.
No, I was watching a jokie, and she and Mint couldn't talk
to each other.
And when you resurrected me and Mimi, I couldn't hear you at
all.
That seems to happen a lot in these games.
It's okay.
Yeah, I was trying to tell you I had your wand.
Oh, okay, I literally ran away with my wand.
I thought it was like a mimic.
I thought there was like one of them.
Yeah, yeah, and I was just like, I was like trying to
communicate.
I was like, yes Yes Did you see the fucking skull spider up
close?
It was the most horrifying.
No, I did not.
I was too scared There was a skull spider where I didn't
even guys the thing that you were running from it was a
skull Oh my guys, I brought us a friend.
Oh, not this.
I've got us a friend.
Look Now we have a frog He's our little familiar.
Oh, he pukes money!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Look at that.
He just like threw up a gold coin.
That's right.
Oh my god.
I abducted him from this family, so now he lives with us.
That's cool.
All right, look at this.
Wait, what's this?
Ignis legs.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna just quickly go and look and see if there's
another torch down.
Whoa!
Guys, look at these.
I have fire legs.
Ignis tongue.
Wait, let me put you out.
Oh!
Oh, wait, what is this?
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're spinning.
Yeah, I'm spinning fire.
I'm spinning.
Yeah, I'm spinning.
I'm dropping my next distract.
Oh, Ignis, boom.
Limo disconnected.
Oh, my.
Oh, okay.
Wait, that's going to help us.
That's going to help us.
I'm going to kill people.
Yeah, I'll be DPS.
Yeah, that'll be huge.
Yeah.
All right.
I'll pick up the stuff in the basement and sell it.
I think, no, I think it's just...
for potions dog dog my god i need the blessed one and then
you keep saying dog you stay up longer wait really oh really
up dog dog dog dog dog oh my god you're right
all right we just gotta wait is lime back oh lime's back
she's yellow now why are you yellow You scared me.
Wait, I want to be yellow.
You came from the forest.
It scared me.
Wait, she's not talking on my screen now.
Yeah, you're not.
I'm a neighbor.
Yeah, you're not talking at all, um.
Are you sure you have the right mic?
Even if you're talking.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, there we go.
Here you go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
I'm sorry.
I mean, I said, hello.
What did you say her?
What the hell are you?
Is she dead?
she's gonna be okay okay the first thing you do is burn me
alive when i'm dead oh i see how it is i i see igna's tongue
that's right oh my god whoa that's crazy i now know what i
know what you are all the fish all right are we all here are
you all ready let's go Wait, wait, wait, you can sell stuff?
Oh, no, Snuppie's over here.
Oh, yeah.
Well, we can sell things.
Or...
Does that mean you can take stuff that we stashed and...
Oh, she's using the portal to do it.
Oh.
She truly is a wizard.
Oh, because we can get the...
The arcana.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, get the...
Yeah, we can get a...
We can get a wand, yeah.
I didn't have to...
Wait, but, like, what happened to her...
What happened to her frog?
Is he not still spitting money?
Oh, look at her zero dollars.
She was worse than us.
You sold our frog!
That's our golden gold!
Why did you sell the frog?
There's another one.
There's another one over here.
That was our golden gold.
No!
This frog doesn't spit money, stuffy!
That's just the...
Oh, wait.
There's money all day.
There's money.
The frog was our passive income.
She got rid of our passive income.
Betrayer.
I have a bat.
Oh, wait.
you do.
Wait, is that?
You get a bat and we all lose a frog.
We lost our passive income.
Alright, we all...
Wait, what wand was that?
Whoa!
Alright, are we ready?
What is this bat?
I'm happy with my standard wand.
Alright, let's go.
Activating.
If anybody wants the purple one, I can give it to them too.
I'm sad.
Sorry.
Hop dog.
We lost our passive income.
What's the point?
Look at another one.
He was also spitting money.
Tempest.
Bigness tongue.
What the fuck worked?
That last guy.
All right.
heading upstairs.
This is little money.
I'm here for the big money.
The big money is up here.
What do we do with this orb?
I don't know.
Let's see.
Ignis tongue.
What was that?
Not doing anything.
What?
Ignis tongue.
Okay, yeah, that's how it.
Oh my god, that's the best ever.
Ignis tongue.
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah oh shit sorry
It was an accident I swear There's the actual yapp yapp I'm
still Ignis tongue blah blah blah blah oh oh that spell
doesn't do damage on items Oh it doesn't yeah the tongue one
does it oh oh yeah it's like I'm just I need some jars.
Tempest.
Oh shit!
Arrow.
Aerial.
Tempest.
Oh!
Aerial.
Tempest.
Oh.
In this tongue!
Blop blop!
Oh shit!
Blop!
In this tongue!
Oh shit!
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, okay, he doesn't take fire damage,
guys, he doesn't take fire damage, oh, he does not take fire
damage, he does not take fire damage, he does not take fire
damage, he's coming, he's coming, he's coming, he's coming,
he's coming, he's coming,
right now i lost adhp oh wait we're almost oh he's still
there ignis boom oh my god the oh my god the range is not
that great boom i don't know oh i think it's like a mine so
you step on and it explodes um so this is a little awkward
uh how do i get through
I have 22 HP I have 22 wait did you jump down Mimi yeah but
then there's a mine in front of me so I feel like okay wait
up dog
dog oh boy oh I got through okay I made it through Are you
fucking...
Um, he's still here, guys.
Ignis, boom!
Where did I...
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
Oh!
Piano!
Alright.
Ignis, boom!
Ere!
Oh, my God.
Okay, wait.
Ignis!
Nice try.
Ignis tongue
Luxana I still don't know what this does He's right behind
me, isn't he?
He's right behind We lost the fire I know We lost the DPS
Watch out, he's coming He's here, he's right behind me Isn't
he, guys Is she dead?
Wait, I'm dead What the fuck was that?
No!
We lost the fire mage.
Our $50.
The honey's gotta pick it up, right?
Holy crap.
Surely someone will pick it up.
The guy that dropped?
Yeah.
What the hell?
Oh my god, I'm watching stuff.
He's POV.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They definitely knew we died, right?
They should know that.
Sorry.
That's okay.
There are places to hide, but it's tough.
Oh my god.
It is.
We need to get to the exit.
I swear, these guys are stronger than before.
Sword guy, but I think if you crash, there's two.
There's definitely way more.
There's way more than what I was used.
I did not sign up for this job.
This was not in the job description.
I feel like, too.
I was like, can we even kill them?
Like, the amount of spells we shouted.
I thought Doki was supposed to kill these guys for us.
I don't know dokey dokey got hit in the back by the big guy.
I don't know if she should but I could tell him What do you
mean?
I don't know
I don't I don't look to the fire look He was behind me.
Why was I supposed to know he was gonna be behind me?
How was I supposed to know that?
Oh my god, I can only fight use fire magic in front of me
not behind me someone didn't cover my back someone didn't
have my back there oh my god oh my god wait it's just it's
stuff me and I believe in oh my god wait snuffy has 13 HP
snuffy has 13 HP there's a third guy there's a third guy
yeah upstairs where snuffy is oh my god HP and snuffy has
13.
It's not looking too good for her.
Oh, okay.
This is stealth game, actually.
I know, right?
It's literally repo, but like, but we break stuff.
Oh my god!
Oh, no, there's another one.
Yeah.
Wait, it's like Metal Gear Solid.
Is this the Metal Gear Solid reference?
This is just like Metal Gear.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, Stubby.
Oh my god, those juke's!
The juke's?
The juke's!
Oh my god, there's one on each floor.
What the heck?
Wait, that's the extraction.
Why did you go to the castle?
Oh, oh, oh.
Look, Sada.
Teleportana.
Why did you just use the door?
Stop me.
If you could have just...
Please keep my throat.
Stop
me.
You're going to lose so much of my knee because none of us
are at the extraction.
Oh my We have a lot of money We do have a lot of money
That's so true Yeah yeah We do have one more night One more
night We can just make it up for it Yeah yeah yeah Yeah
She's fucking stairs There's no point in free Why do we
bring her body It's not like It's not like Maybe I keep my
items Oh you poor fool You poor fool Oh my god I hope she
has my wand I don't know I don't know She's holding two
wands guys she's all dang it take it take it take it take it
oh it's
okay we 400 we just need 400 gold that that's yeah one more
day okay free wand snuffy i couldn't figure out how to grab
your little friend unfortunately why is like okay wait why
he's still here he's still alive i don't know why he's here
i don't have the Wait, Lyme!
Why did you keep the wind wands?
You know we get free wands here, right?
I just picked it up because there was something on the
floor.
Oh, you just randomly grabbed.
Yeah, yeah, grab whatever.
She was moving purely on survivalist.
I got you this because Snuffy killed yours.
My new frog friend!
We got her passive income.
We can buy if you guys want to try the wand of a looser.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe you could turn into a frog.
all right here we go uh load oculus what the fuck we have an
eyeball that's a that oh my god i'm all the way over here oh
is it like um i'm like i'm like oh is this your drone
experience it's like your drone yeah i'm a drone i'm a drone
wait how do i go how do i stop this go back in go back your
eye.
Go back at my body.
Oh, oh, oh, it's time to send.
Okay, okay.
Let's see.
We got poof me.
Do you think somebody will argue with you if you describe
yourself as a chair?
Yeah.
Don't sit down with your arrow.
We have...
gonna plan on playing musical chairs whoa wait what happened
you kind of oh there's so many oh but yeah he's dancing
you're like you're you're the deceptive one now no and then
there's shrink anna hello wait it's my hello my baby i'm
baby How tiny am I?
It's like Mario.
I want to step on her.
Why are you?
Get out of her under my cloak.
It changes everyone's voices.
Those are all of them.
Oh, sorry.
Oh.
It changes all of them for me.
The voices.
But that's...
All right.
Wait, where's Lymo?
Oh, there you are.
Are we all ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
All right.
Let's go.
Ready.
Oh, wait, we're Snuffy.
I swear to God, she sells our frog again.
I swear to fucking God.
I got this tangerine.
I swear to God, Snuffy, you sell our passive income again.
I'm going to earn passive income with my new music career.
Final night, guys.
Let's lock in.
Let's lock it.
Okay, you just, I just lost 5 HP.
I just lost 5 HP.
I wonder who did that.
What's that mean?
Aerial.
I'm heading upstairs.
That's where the big money's at.
Big money.
Looking for a torch.
You're for the big mula.
Tempest.
Oh, there's an eyeball, guys.
Be nice.
There's an eyeball over there.
You looked at me.
Maybe he likes my music.
Oh, he's tiny!
Tempest!
Oh, wait, he's gone.
Oh, okay, cool.
He was so embarrassed by his small size.
It was above average, man.
Don't shy-size-shame him.
Well, it's messed up size-shaming that poor eye.
Oh my god, he's back, he's back.
Keep size-shaming him.
Oh.
But who's down here?
She's a really dark chamber.
Hi.
Tempest.
I'm looking for a source of light.
Me too.
I'm trying to figure out where to go.
Wait, who's over there?
Hello?
I'm scared.
Hi.
I go down.
There's no down.
Where are the doors?
I don't know.
I'm- it's so dark.
I have no light source.
Oh, hey guys.
I think here, I think.
I tried to go down, but I can't see shit.
Are there stairs here?
Crazy.
There's no stairs.
It's just- it's just down- Yeah.
I think there's stuff over here.
The stairs here just goes back to the upstairs.
Yeah.
I think this is a dead end, guys.
I'm gonna go this way.
Have I gone here?
Yeah, I've gone here before, right, guys?
Yeah, I went here, and then I went to that corridor.
And then...
We go back here.
We just need, like, 50...
Oh, wait.
There's another upstairs.
Have I been here?
I'm so...
Oh, and there's another upstairs?
Oh, my God.
There's stairs for days.
Wait, and then there's...
Where the fuck?
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, oh!
God, okay, Ariel.
Oh, no.
What's wrong with you?
Tempest.
Aeros.
You jerk.
What do you mean?
It was like reflex.
I thought you were an enemy.
I had lag.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, and then.
No, no, no.
It was lag.
it was like yeah I have like 300 ping right now no you don't
have 300 latency I have 300 you don't know that you don't
see my ping I have 300 latency are you paying judging me no
no no I have an external program that I love what happened
there's a guy downstairs wait there's a frog
$75 Guys, I'm downstairs right now.
I'm scared.
Up dog.
Dog.
Oh!
Okay, downstairs safe.
Go downstairs.
Oh, downstairs no longer safe.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, I have the other staircase.
I think we have to go upstairs.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
There's like nothing up here.
The second, the third floor?
I meant more that.
Oh, oh.
Trigana.
Of course.
Help me.
Okay, a chair is not going to help you.
I thought that was the one that makes you both follow me.
I don't think the chair...
All right, I jukeed him.
I juke them again I can't keep jukeing this I leave Wait
Where the fuck am I Oh wait this is new
Oh shit I found it Orpies Surely this would take me to the
extraction point right
Wait where is this area where am i somebody's already been
here oh this is the upstairs is where the original warp was
yeah oh there's the revive okay if anybody dies we know
where to go that's good that's good tempest we have to find
extraction soon though oh that's a mimic i area yeah that's
a fucking mimic why would there be such a giant giant jar
just sitting there there's no way that thing is real I
refuse to believe it oh yeah area area that 75 where the
fuck am I I don't hear anyone I'm scared it's at the East?
War beast, okay.
Oh, no.
Where the fuck is the extraction?
Where am I?
Okay.
Oh, hi.
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
Have we gone up yet?
I don't know.
Oh, oh, do not go up.
Shrink it, shrink it, shrink it, shrink it!
Where is it?
It's gone.
No, no, it's right here.
It's right here.
I think, I think, I think up is extraction.
You have to shrink it.
okay shrink on oh i don't think that was i don't think that
worked i don't think that worked i don't think that worked i
don't think it didn't work it didn't work it didn't work
okay watch this up dog wait you guys oh my god never mind
yeah yeah we're coming we're coming we're coming we're
coming
And you're just downstairs.
You're just downstairs.
You don't go anywhere else.
Guys, we have to find the extraction.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll be a hero.
Oh, wait.
That's just...
He just has bombs.
I'm not...
I have nothing to worry about.
He's just chilling.
The extraction has to be here somewhere.
Okay, I've seen that area.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna be a hero.
shows up I know what to do okay and I also have this I'll
just find extraction camp there and then and if nobody shows
up I peace out and then I will be the hero and everybody
will know what I did today where the fuck is the Tempest
where Where is the extraction?
Oh, why are all the doors open?
Somebody's been here before.
Hello?
Oh.
Wait, are you guys up here?
Hello?
Oh!
Are you doing the time quiz?
What is going on?
Nimi?
Oh, there you go.
Nimi's doing, she's doing a vocal quiz right now.
I don't hear anything.
She's locked in.
Oh, I hear.
Almost there, almost there.
Oh, okay.
Where are you?
Dang.
I'm below you.
Oh, you were so close.
Hey.
All right.
Exit time.
Oh, shit.
Tahani.
Oh, dog.
Oh.
Okay, I'm okay.
She's doing the time.
Yeah, she's doing her music quiz.
Yeah, yeah.
She's still doing it.
It's okay.
We still have a minute.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We could just, okay, if she doesn't show up.
In a minute, we peace out.
I think Stuffy is helping her right now.
Is there anything else around?
I mean, we can watch it here.
Look, let's watch it.
Oh, yeah, we could watch them, yeah.
Look, there she is.
Look at her.
I think Stuffy is watching right now.
Yeah, Stuffy is watching.
There she is watching.
And then, ooh.
Oh.
Did she get out?
It seems like it.
I think that's what I think she can at least leave between
attempts maybe no.
Yeah.
Oh We did oh yeah, she's going she's coming.
Oh, they're coming.
They're coming.
All right the moment we see the the ghost we've come here
Come here even we have to stare at their faces.
We have to clock out Follow our voices.
We're up here.
We're up.
I think I have to press it.
Oh Trinkana
one wait wait one two three four wait there's four of us
where's the fifth oh oh there she is oh yeah I was like wait
there's four of us and I see a tiny stuff he's just jumping
around.
You're like, I did it!
I did it!
We actually made it!
Big money!
Oh my god.
Are you happy?
Are you happy, boss?
We did it!
We brought you so much!
We brought you so much money!
Are we pleased you?
Look, what?
Here, I'll give you a little dance, father.
What am I?
What are you?
I don't know.
21 gold smackeronies?
Dad, you suck.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the allowance.
We're all five of us to share.
That's why I'm daddy's favorite.
Wait, there's...
Can I have a fire one?
The grotesque one on his back.
That's the cheapest, too.
more frogs i want to fire one it's super expensive oh oh
nice frogs are slowly puking out money see look at that we
could have had three frogs things our stash things as we've
gone maybe there's enough man oh yeah i i stashed them oh
yeah me too we could sell some of this stuff yeah oh well
you spit money too oh nice yay all right Let's grab some
items to sell.
I am going to sell the mystery egg.
And then one of my feathers.
How did I make it move?
Alright.
Take what move?
The thing.
Did you figure out how to make the thing move?
What's the thing?
It was pitch.
But it's confusing.
I think.
Oh, no.
It was like putting the bowl in the middle of the hole.
But it looked really contrived.
We didn't sell some more stuff.
And we should be able to afford the fire wand.
We're selling some more stuff downstairs.
I love the final one.
Yeah, yeah.
You guys want to, do you guys like this wand?
Or I can sell it too.
I don't.
What is that?
You should keep your special one.
Wait, keep a special one.
Yeah, you should keep it.
Special.
I just realized your hat lights up when you speak.
That's cute.
Oh, look at those.
You're right.
That's so cute.
Fill containers.
Oh, wait, we might, we need to get the containers.
We're pissed because you get 250 chaos.
I like the wizard from Marwinder leader.
Dude, I want to buy the blessed wand, okay?
i'm gonna grab more items frog speaker burner all right
midnight sage i'll buy i'll sell that too we don't need
potions right like who needs potions what do are we we don't
need any of this like it feels like the potions fucking suck
because the cool down period seems like really really it's
like one use and like the duration is not that great.
Oh, wait.
Did you guys sell stuff already?
I sold.
We sold for the fire wand.
Oh, okay.
I can sell this real quick.
Please take my mushroom.
I can sell my wand if you guys want a different wand.
I can sell.
I can sell the clothes on my back.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't want everyone to have a wand.
It's a mine.
So.
Yeah, yeah.
That seems strong.
The thing is, you can't really control where...
Oh, yeah, you have to talk when you're...
Yeah, you have to be like, Baa, Baa, Baa, Baa, Baa, Baa,
Baa.
Are those sword guys really invincible?
I don't know.
I can't kill them.
With the wind at least.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, do we have...
Oh, it.
Are we ready?
What else is arcane magic?
Dog.
I think it's only three dogs Yeah, we can only have three
dogs per person I'm extracting, but then I'm also gonna go
pee Dog Okay Nothing bad will happen to you
Oh, I should have looked at the grimoire for my custom wand
You're right I'm so curious what like High bastion The
little like puzzles will reward you with if we could
actually It better be good.
Yeah, right.
I think it's like a wand.
Arrow.
Oh, because I have to use it.
Sorry!
Sorry to be...
Arrow.
Look, you don't think he's using the bathroom.
I deserve that.
Oh, that's right.
It's your tongue.
I feel it.
I could do this again.
That's great.
I like that.
Oh.
That's great.
I
like killing the little babies
Alright, I'm back It's time Time to clock into my 9-to-5
Wizardy job Yeah, there is fall damage Yeah, there always
has been fall damage Ouch,
ouch Stop talking, stop talking live Sticks and stones may
break my bones words words will hurt me no I always knew
there were fall damage I was just wondering who was gonna
jump off oh the rooftop oh isn't it beautiful no there
usually isn't oh I see the extraction room area yeah yeah
what's wrong with you shrink on yeah what's that gonna do to
me nothing I'll just get bigger back again I can't
understand what you're saying.
That's what you're saying.
That's what you sound like.
That's for you.
You want to see me dance like a little monkey?
You know, like those little monkeys that you crank in the
little music box and the monkey.
Little monkey dance.
I think this is where we came from.
I think so too.
Wait, actually, I'm lost.
Wait, no, we haven't went through this door.
This door looks...
Yes, that's where we came from.
Oh, wait, no, this is where we started.
Everything, all these rooms start blurring together.
Wait, where's new?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Lymo knows where to go.
I follow Lymo.
Lime will make us money Or we're gonna get evicted There's
some stuff going on What the fuck is going on over there?
What is that?
Oh, that's an eyeball!
It's an eyeball!
There we go.
Nice, $12.
You're welcome, guys.
I earned this $12 today.
I say dollars and it thinks...
I don't know what counts as arcane magic, so I haven't been
able to do complete one of the contracts.
I think this is a revive room.
Oh, wait, this is a...
This is a revive room.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we need to go there.
Yeah, I totally...
I know the flame one is pretty bad.
It doesn't really do much.
Yeah.
Aerial.
My beautiful.
Yay.
Oh!
Portal.
Good.
Bye.
Ariel.
Oh, I was gonna say it didn't break.
Is that a mimic?
Ariel.
Oh.
Oh, let's go.
We got five.
Oh, there's another portal here.
Or is that the same one?
Oh, wait, there's another one.
Come here.
Where does this take us?
Sound?
Where's the door?
Oh, oh, oh, the door hasn't been open.
So wait, I think we found the extraction No, that's just
another crystal.
Never mind.
I'm so confused.
I'm so lost in me.
I'm just There's more crystals.
Okay, where does this go?
North.
Are we not?
Is that where we were?
Is that I don't know.
I've lost track.
Oh, but I broke this jar.
Okay.
Hey, we figured it out.
like in a little crystal teleportation maze there's another
mini game over here if you guys want to try oh there's a
hundred dudes there like the big spider it's okay we have we
have uh our fire mage she can just burn them down scale
based it does like no damage man arrow he's got yapp more
you gotta go blah blah blah blah i think it was this way i
don't remember yeah this way Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
I'm with you, Snuffy.
I got a frog!
Pass some income!
Let's go!
Yeah, here it is.
Oh, wait, there's a thing here.
Somebody was here.
Could it be a... Wait, what's the...
So we have to put the blue...
Oh, we have to make it so...
do we have to like balance it I think so I can't like lift
them though like do we do we put on this side or the other
side no we have to put on the other side yeah oh the eyes
here the eyes here the eyes here wearing it down too much
okay we I didn't even see the okay there we go oh my god We
have to balance it out.
Yeah It's like geometry That's not that's not our friend.
That's that's a mimic.
That's a mimic.
That's not that's not our friend Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I thought I was like who's that over there?
Okay Oh, it's working Oh my god, it's actually working.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, we're figuring this out.
Can you go kill the eyeball?
He just keeps like...
Um, I really only just have Matt.
Mine's just win magic, so he doesn't do it.
Okay, yeah, me too.
The mimic kind of came in, straightened a bunch and then
left, I guess.
The eyeball and...
Just wants to be included.
And then we're like, get out!
Yeah, I have two eyeballs.
Oh, they do hurt.
They just got a lot of fire.
They only hurt when...
Oh, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think it's almost there.
Oh, don't stand there.
Don't stand there.
If your stamina is at, uh, oh, oh.
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
Yeah.
What do we get?
What did we get?
Oh, my favorite wand.
What did you get?
The middle preview is just on the stairs here.
Oh, oh, oh.
Are we okay?
Blink Oh, oh my god, thank god Like where does it Oh my god,
where am I aiming at?
Okay, it's like It's like tracer blinks Oh my god, I can't
say tracer blinks Oh I'm sort of being a gate kept right now
I'm getting camped Oh swap hello are you alive oh there's
two eyes there's two eyes neemie take cover take cover that
big tower wait what's over on the other side neemie is
everyone alive yeah we're all still alive we're just sort of
stuck one is i think snuffy and them are like outside the
room wait what was over here neemie um i don't remember oh
that's where the mimic went it wasn't it there was a sword
guy okay okay i'm okay i just slipped and fell i'm pretty
sure this way is where the extraction is most likely i found
the extraction at one point oh really okay i lost it think
about it okay just think it was through a teleporter oh
where am i okay think and blink sound the same apparently
all right this one fucking sucks here neem you can have this
one i give i give you a gift of a shitty one oh thank you
yeah yeah like whatever i say you like tp some words it's
not it it's not it blink just sounds too much like
everything every other word like every other yeah i see how
your everywhere where is it um just think concentrate neemie
concentrate oh my
god there's two goblins over there I think Puzzler...
No, I think this way was Puzzler Room, wasn't it?
Wait, no.
This is different.
Um...
Wait, what is this?
I am a little lost.
Oh, this is the Revive Place.
Oh, okay.
Wait, no, we've been here then.
We've been here.
We found the Revive Place before.
I remember.
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'm okay.
There's no...
Oh, wait, wait.
There's crystals here.
Oh, wait.
No, this is the...
Remember, we did our little TP Crystal Dance here?
Yes, but the extraction point was near one of the crystals.
Okay, this one, north?
Maybe this one.
This one says north.
The other one is...
North.
Wait, they're both north.
They're both north?
They're both north.
Then where does the other crystal go?
Wait, where's the other...
You see the, like, castle there.
the other north crystal and then oh no i don't neemie i have
a feeling we might not make it back home neemie we're 30
seconds neemie i don't wait i don't think we're gonna oh oh
we will we will be the heroes we gotta book it we gotta be
we will be the heroes of the story i don't think i think the
other girls are, I don't think the other girls have found
the extraction.
Oh!
Bye!
Areas.
She was outside the circle.
She was out.
She didn't make it I lost those ones She didn't make it No
no just I couldn't move You guys should have pushed me in
You know what I did I did I did I knew I saw her Outside the
circle and I said Ariel and pushed you for I pushed you
further away Literally, I crashed Like, Mint used her spell
And then it just instantly crashed my game But I guess I
kept all my items Also, Mint, why didn't you use your spell
in the circle?
Mint, have this wand I don't like it as much I just want my
torch You can have that Are you sure?
It's not a great wand It's not an actual great wand I will
have to say Wait, what's the wand of minor?
I can do one more.
What is the...
Grab Onna.
Grab-on-a.
Grab Anna!
Grab-ana!
Luxor!
Hell no!
Fuck you!
Grab Anna!
I grabbed you!
What is that?
I gotta watch the Surat!
Look at this!
Okay, go on three person!
Go on three person!
Grab Anna.
Alright, grab people.
Luxana.
What is Luxana?
It's so sweet.
I'll miss my little baby.
Lux.
Teleportana.
Whoa.
We had so many frauds.
Oh my god.
I forget to pick up the gold that they leave.
Yeah, yeah.
Money, money, money, money, money, money.
Must be funny.
Grabana.
How do I, like, chuck people away?
I chucked her away one time.
Grabana.
Whoa.
Yeah, but I saw, like, the first time I used it, I chucked
someone away.
I freaking have the worst.
Grabana.
Wait, that's the one I have.
Oh Wait, that means we can grab someone like closer to us.
All right.
Are you guys ready?
I'm extracting
Grabana the splints
I don't even know what Luxana is I forgot the grim war
again.
Wait haunted mona Wait, that's new were yesterday grab on oh
sorry grab on a grab on a oh i can grab on to items but
that's cool oh bye where did i where did i go like i don't
even know where i teleported tempest
There's so much cool items up here though.
Oh, it's so cool.
I have my own little lasers.
Are you?
Oh, oh!
Gravata!
I do not grab the eye.
Do not grab the eye.
Might not have been the smartest thing I've done.
There is an eye downstairs, guys.
You can hear more of your beautiful voice.
If you, like, yell at objects.
It's great.
I will.
Come on, Nimi.
We're moving to the next room.
Oh, there's the eyeball.
Oh, no.
Grabana!
Oh, don't let her get me!
There is an eye right behind us.
Luxana.
Oh, Luxana is, like, light.
Oh, okay.
Don't do that.
Grabana.
That makes sense.
Lux, we've light, I guess.
Grabana.
That's right, dodged!
See, I learned from Snuffy's mistake and moved step to the
left.
Oh, that was expensive.
I don't know, I like this.
There's so many big vowels.
Rabana!
No, no, no!
Making so much money!
Yay!
We're hard workers, guys.
Oh, there's a slime.
Oh, we don't have the...
Did anyone buy the gross test one?
Because we're supposed to pee on it.
No.
Oh, no peeing on the slime, I guess.
Not this time.
I got something expensive.
Tempest.
Aerial.
Oh, guys, you can't push the slime.
There is a...
Where is the slime?
She's up here with me.
No.
But, like, you can't push.
Apparently, the slime is unpushable.
Oh, I could just walk past it, I guess.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Let me break this wall and go over there.
All right.
There's nothing.
How do I get up top?
Oh, oh.
There's a dragon?
Far oil?
Oh!
What?
I just saw someone get abducted.
I saw someone.
Oh.
Guys.
Um.
Oh, that's.
that's awkward that's how that was little um hey guys um i
saw nimi get abducted by a dragon and then i ran away um so
uh the last words i heard was there's a dragon and oh my god
oh my god that was a one-shot that was a one-shot that was a
one-shot alive no she's dead she's dead she's dead
lexana oh my god why did i come back here i thought this it
would hello neem are you still alive up
dog it's the risk I'm willing to take um so the gesture is
on the high ground right now and mint is yeah there there's
a oh yeah so the gesture is uh he looked at mint and then he
died and then she died it was uh oh what the fuck is that
you see that I'm a little guy slime cube.
There's a gigantic... What the fuck is that?
Did you see that?
Yeah, we found the guy in the basement.
Oh, my gosh.
Astralize are scary.
Oh, right behind you or right in front of us?
Right, right this way.
And there's also a giant slime cube.
Oh, he came back?
That's what was going on with that.
Yeah.
So... This is exactly where we came.
We need to go forward.
Oh, okay.
I thought that...
I thought forward was where we came from.
Oh, no, I'm lost.
I already I'm already messed up No, this is this is the new
area Yeah, I mean what will we do about you?
Maybe genuinely my sense of direction maybe maybe we'd be
dead honestly.
We could just be dead Oh, I don't Oh, that door was
unopened.
Oh, there's another sword guy here.
Oh, that's new Yeah, this is all new.
Tempest you're careful oh wow i'm getting much money watch
this grabana
did it grab him
oh and i said grabana and then i said did it grab him and
then i got grabbed and then
yeah sometimes the spells don't work in our favor
Oh, shit, the mimic!
Was it a snuffy mimic?
I have no...
Are you alive?
Oh, hey, Nivi, I thought you...
I'm good, I'm good.
Because things just don't...
Okay, the fact that the gesture is a one-shot is pretty
fucked up, I will say.
I know.
You were like our test subject, too.
You were like, we're like, oh, I wonder what happens if you
get crashed.
I
Think maybe I wasted money on that shitty ass grab on a one
Where did snuffy go where was she by herself?
Oh
My god the jukes of the century, oh, she doesn't know they
can open doors She doesn't know they can open doors.
Oh, she made it back with them.
She made it back.
Oh, that's Wait, that's not Nimi.
That's not me that's that's that's not me He's like
why are you looking at her why i don't think she could oh oh
she just like put her as long as i don't look at you i'll be
okay why didn't why didn't stuff be going
i i don't even know where she is and then where the rest of
the crew is yeah this map is huge there's like a supposed to
be a monolith or some shit too she
like i wish there was like a world map so we can see where
Is that all that?
Yeah, something like that.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
You're real and alive.
You're also real and alive.
Oh, Nimi and Stuffy.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Nimi has one HP.
One HP.
Yeah, one HP.
One HP in a dream.
What is Lymo?
I'm scared.
Are you up above us?
It's at the end of this corridor.
Oh.
Oh, who the hell is that?
Yeah, we went down.
Nimi knows the way back to it.
Did she just say dead?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, you know, Snuffy was not the one I expected
to have died there.
What happened?
Oh, the clown got me.
Oh, you got grabbed.
Yeah, it's okay.
We're the grab crew.
sitting in the corner.
I have no idea.
Yeah, this game.
It has like, well, I think it's like, we're at like, like,
third stage now.
Yeah.
The difficulty spike is crazy, though.
Pretty, yeah, it is.
They probably expect you to use, like, the, the, um, the
potions and stuff.
We're just raw dogs.
Yeah, we're just raw.
Yeah, we're like, we just sell all our ingredients for more
wines.
We're like, we don't need potions.
We just, We just want more wands.
We just want more wands.
Like wands that we lose.
Oh no!
No!
Now we're gonna watch 1 HP Nimi.
I'm...
Yeah, 1 HP.
She's like... She just...
Someone's just gonna sneeze on her and then it's gonna be
over.
Oh!
Hey, welcome to the grabbed crew.
That gesture was bullshit.
He turned right around and followed me.
All right, we did get we got 163 though.
We have one more night, guys.
Final night.
Okay, I can do the one more night, but I can't stop.
Yeah, I want to know if we...
Yeah, I want to know if we make it.
Also, if we don't make it, we can see what the death
animation is like.
Oh, everybody grab your new one.
LG, LG.
wait i'm gonna i'm gonna see we can get the grotesque one so
we can pee on the slime all right let's let's sell our stuff
since it's lg boop boop boop we don't need this these angry
i don't think we're gonna get to three thousand six hundred
guys it's tough i'm selling stuff because i want to buy a
grotesque one
beautiful she's so cool three more all right Sell, sell,
sell.
Bye, bye, bye.
We don't need these mushrooms.
We want more ones.
Me or lunch money frog.
These take my mushrooms.
He gave us an extra.
Grab the frogs.
We'll give you more money.
All right.
I got it.
When you cuddle them.
We got it.
We got pissed yuck again.
Good.
I'm tipping the musician.
Oh, it is!
Hot Cross buns!
Oh!
Wait.
I'm dancing.
Mary had a little lamb.
Little lamb.
This place was white as snow.
Final night.
Alright,
let's go.
Oh wait, I do.
Oh wait, here, here.
Oh, I have a wind wand here.
Oh, I got one.
Alright.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
You need me.
I have another one too.
We trade...
Thank you.
I have...
I only need one one.
Where is the...
Wait, how do we find containers?
Arrow.
Wait, what do the containers look like, guys?
Containers?
This one?
Piss yuck.
What do you...
You peed it!
Yay!
We did it.
Wait, it increased?
Yeah, wait.
Can we...
Can we break it?
Do we get gold?
wait wait oh I increased the value with my piss all right
let's go we get more money if I piss on it all right here we
go the value increases wait can I do the this piss yuck can
I piss on the is it filling in oh okay it doesn't work he I
need to hydrate, rehydrate.
I'm going forward.
Oh, someone's been here.
Piss yuck.
Is it?
Stop.
You peeing over the side?
No, I'm peeing on the paintings.
I'm creasing the value.
It gave me $8.
Oh, God.
Oh.
He's over there.
Yeah, okay.
have any fire though we gotta find a torch oh yeah we don't
have luxana too wait what was that i don't know where am i
can't see right now i know this game is so dark it is so
dark i'm like where are okay the only way across oh that's
that's what oh wait no that's that's neem okay i thought it
was a are you really are you really neem me play us a song
if you're the real neem me Oh.
Where?
One.
Oh.
I'm real.
Oh, you're real.
Which way do I go?
Up.
Let's go up.
Wait, where did our bard go?
Mimi?
Where did our bard go?
She was with you.
Yeah.
I thought she was following me.
Wait, piss yuck!
What are we piss yucking?
This...
Whoa, look at that!
Look at that!
It like makes a sound effect and everything!
There's an eyeball behind you?
It's okay, I have a pillar, we'll see.
Mimi, are you real?
Oh, Mimi, no!
Mimi, no!
Oh, you're fine, you're fine!
Wait, yeah, yeah.
Yay!
Disgust!
I got on your road.
I saw it.
Nimi, how much HP do you have right now?
56.
Oh, okay.
You still...
56.
She's still okay.
She's still healthy.
She doesn't have to go to the hospital yet.
There's an eyeball.
Yeah, yeah.
We have to pill her, though.
Stay underneath her.
It's a fish.
It's a fish now.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, doesn't it talking?
Yeah, yeah, she is.
Oh, there's a guy behind us?
I can't hear her.
Oh, no.
Okay, I can turn her into a fish and then it'll reset it.
Does that work?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fish me.
I'll fish her.
Okay, I hear you now.
Oh, okay.
I sneezed at her too.
Hello, who's this?
Wait, this is really expensive.
This thing.
Wait, which one?
Oh, how do you break it though?
This big statue.
Piss, yuck.
I didn't shrink it before and I would break it.
What if I pee on?
Oh, if I pee on it.
I desecrate it.
There you go.
All right.
I still find three more containers.
What the?
Eyeball, eyeball, eyeball.
I can't fish yuck it.
Oh, achoo.
Achoo.
Oh.
Oh, be careful.
Be careful.
Oh, it disappeared.
It disappeared.
Fish yuck.
I mean, piss yuck.
I'm peeing on the statues Good money It is Yeah I didn't
realize it was like Just desecrating everything Oh yeah And
then we You can get behind it Oh You guys The night is here
Oh The way I fish shock Fish shock He's a fish He's a fish
Go go go go Go go go There's a pointer Go Go
Morty, one of your shit ever.
Wait, that's two Limus.
Yeah, I just saw two Limus there.
Oh, yeah.
Those are two Limus.
And they're not destroyed.
Wait, what was that sound?
That's a goblin.
See?
He has a sword.
There's a shuck.
Oh, my God.
It's bad.
It's a bad, bad, bad.
It's very bad.
Teleporter Where was the teleporter?
Come here, baby, ah
How did you drop your wand?
I don't know, he shaked The Coughlin took my wand He robbed
me is a fucking thief He took my fucking Mimi?
Mimi, come back downstairs Jump down, we'll catch you Oh
god, oh god We won't catch you, Nima, we have to go Um Guy
reminds me of the Pinar Snipper guy The what Snipper guy
What are you watching?
Nimi?
I don't, I gave her my wand The goblin stole my The goblin
stole it Wait go grab go grab that torch this one oh my god
maybe oh hello oh oh oh did you just transport yeah oh wait
wait did you use that teleport yeah okay so that's where we
were gonna go yeah so i guess it doesn't matter oh
everybody's here um so um well neemie neemie's stuck
upstairs and i think there's a lot of stuff upstairs yeah
okay um and i love my piss yuck water oh wait extractions
here extractions here wait we made it guys we made it oh
wait but but we have we have to get Nimi because if we don't
get Nimi yeah we have to get with yeah yeah we have to get
Nimi there's a big thing right there what is that yeah
there's a bunch of baddies and so we have to grab her
because or we won't make it for the day Yeah, I don't have
faith, but I'm just, like, trying to create a buffer here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, just in case.
All right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, so all of us can't die.
All right, we got to do a rescue mission.
I want to go get Nimmy, though.
We can do a rescue mission.
We will rescue her.
I have nothing on me except for a torch, but we can do it.
Jimmy, if you can hear us, jump down.
Wait, I got a frog.
Wait.
It's okay, guys.
I got a frog.
No, what are those?
Wait, is this...
Is that Nimi?
Nimi?
Is that you?
Get it, get it.
No.
It says get, get, get, get.
You're her new mom.
Ew.
Oh, oh, oh, you put Snuffy.
Wait!
Snuffy!
No, no, no.
She's dead.
Holy no.
Do we have, do we have any idea what the how much money
are you guys okay
oh no no yeah yeah wait at the extraction yeah wait at the
extraction get out of here you're not allowed in this room
no boys allowed
oh oh oh oh we should be allowed to like burn them you can't
even burn this guy that's okay lime was doing lime was doing
a but oh shit okay I'm okay I'm okay lime was getting a
buffer right now we can watch her go away all right well
watch her I believe in lime moon I almost died I have six
HP.
It's alright.
I have a frog.
Look.
I got us more passive income.
We're gonna be so rich.
Biden, not 401k.
Oh, she's gotten in his body.
Yeah, but it doesn't matter, though, because she has to
revive her.
Does she know what...
I don't know how much...
Yeah.
I think it's like minus 80 or something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know how much money Mimi's worth.
Yeah, Lamo!
Well, because I think you lose less money.
So hopefully we will have enough.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
All right, Neemie What is- Oh, no.
Yeah.
Why won't she come up here?
Neemie, get over here.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a joint effort.
Join effort.
Yeah, weekend at Neemies.
There we go.
Oh shit.
Oh my gosh.
She like exploded us.
There we go.
Yeah.
I started.
uh yay update
yeah yay yay oh oh oh oh
so wait this is kind of fun on our last game we get to see
what happened yeah we did see yeah yeah we did that on
purpose we we sammed bagged on purpose yeah yeah yeah boss
you got it boss boss look Mimi was she was a valuable member
up dog dog dog oh no he's gonna oh no i think he squashed us
i thought we did pretty good though sir i thought look
neemie was a oh wait i can hear you oh i hear yeah yeah it
took a while i didn't realize hello well i'm blue hello we
lost all our frogs no i have one right here oh yay yeah well
i think i think this is like reset to zero basically but
yeah it's just like repo that's fun though i had fun that
they didn't have fireball for like a game above yeah they
have the fire spit but it ain't the same as fireball you
know fireball no that shit's basic watch me watch watch me
watch me watch me whip watch me nana mr beast
wait which one is that that's it mr beast
Yeah, she's like No, no, no Oh, did you guys notice that it
resets like the audio to 50 as well Oh, yeah, yeah, I was
like Yeah, I was like, why is everybody so quiet now?
Oh, you're right, yeah What the
fuck is that, Evo?
That's just crouching What is that crouching?
It's just crouching.
I thought you were doing an Emo there.
Mm-mm.
They're so cute.
This game is fun and I appreciate it.
I'm pretty sure you're gonna update this game even more.
Did you see the game that Lam was suggested?
Oh yeah, I see.
Yeah, we did do that one too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That shows.
I had fun, guys.
Thanks for joining me today.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, you know, we made it.
We'll have a wonderful night.
We made it further than I expected.
Good night, Lama.
Go sleep.
Thank you.
Goodbye, everyone.
Bye-bye, Lama.
Bye-bye.
GG's, everyone.
Let's dance so quick.
Goodbye.
Wait, who is the...
Good vibes.
I want to spend myself in the air.
Up dog.
Yeah, you can't...
Can you up dog while you're dancing?
I don't think you can.
You have to...
I can do the splits.
Wait, watch me do the splits.
Okay.
Wait, oh, you jump, you jump in V.
Jump in V.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, these dance lessons are paying off, guys.
I just got stuck in the ground GG's guys GG's Oh we all have
a good day Bye bye guys Bye bye
Oh my god that's a John Asmint Oh my god my all my little
hats They're wizards poofed It's like the Jedi.
It's like the fucking Jedi.
They all poofed and all they did was leave their little
wizard hats.
That was fun.
I think like it's definitely a hard game.
It was...
The game.
The game is definitely pretty hard because it's like...
I don't know if you can kill the enemies.
That's the thing.
I have no idea if the enemies are...
killable because we kept fucking yelling spells at them and
they're either like incredibly tanky or like or like you
just gotta like use it as like use as a way to push them
away yeah
probably can like phasmo i feel like we haven't even seen
like the extent of how many enemies there are in this game
but that was really fun i'm glad i uh i organized this
collab because i saw a lot of videos about yapp yapp and so
i was just like i want to i want to check this out with the
sloppy sisters yeah i don't think they should but i think i
think if we i guess like because they're like oh we just
kill the monsters and there's no threat you know but that
jester was fucking crazy that that jester the fact that he
is like a one-shot i was like are you what the like how why
is this guy one shot like what can we do and he's so big
he's so fucking big on my screen like i feel like um but i
think the con i like the concept i like that it's like it's
basically repo but like you break things instead of um you
break things instead of trying to salvage stuff so i don't
know i think that's a cool concept and the that you can yell
random spells i hope they add more wands to her magic spells
and stuff there should be a lot of fun things you can do
i think the one should more i think more wands and more
abilities would be pretty nice you know we haven't done this
in a long time but let's super wait do i have super chats
today i was gonna say super chat reading and i was like wait
do i have super chats on do i have super chats for today
anyway oh i do i do all right let let us go to the let us go
to the pool the beach real quick in the winter let me find
it's been a while here we go to the beach in the winter best
time to go to the beach it is less crowded if you think
about it it is the best time because there's less people
there see yeah
all right here we go help I'm all right I'm gonna go refill
my water real quick um and then um and then I'll be back
guys hello I am back oh did I not did it not go did it not
do the thing wait let me check
what happened
what happened wait What?
What happened?
Wait, let me fix this.
That's weird.
Oh, here.
I fixed it.
There we go.
It's fixed.
It's fixed now.
Alright.
Um.
That was weird.
I didn't... I was like...
Where did it go?
there we go also shout out to neemie for making us the
wizard hats uh she provided the little wizard hat as a
little asset for all of us so shout out to her um um she was
playing it on max fov too we were like because apparently um
the uh the the fucking f like the i guess like it was really
bad for people who have motion sickness and i was just like
we were like all of us had like different fovs mine was like
i didn't really like the f of the default fov uh i know like
mint set hers to 70 the default was 90 i put mine at 80 and
then we were asking me and she's like mine's maxed out and i
was like wow she wanted to see everything yeah um oh my gosh
i'm like all over the place right now like i have so many
deadlines and so many behind the scenes things i am so
stressed out at the moment because uh february is hell month
you think this week there is like the end of the event no
next week we have our pubg blind spot sponsor tournament um
they contacted me uh to help with i guess like being the
face of their first official na tournament um because they
do have another tournament in korea as well that's going
around the same time but they wanted uh me to be like the
face of their first the public na tournament uh so huge
shout out to pubg blindspot for sponsoring me i was a little
nervous about it because i was just like it's a lot of work
because it was like we told them like it is a lot because it
is during we have another thing next week as well before the
pubg tournament as well as the anniversary and end of and
and dad's birthday and so like um they helped a lot with
like making a lot all the graphics and the assets but riding
the pubg one on it's going to be a multi-stream for the
announcement um the announcement is going to be a
multi-stream because apparently there's like a twitch thing
there's going to be like i think twitch drops going on so
they wanted uh they wanted there to be on twitch but i did
tell them like oh uh my main audience is on youtube uh and
so they asked if we could multi-stream so i was like yeah
it's fine it's an announcement so i don't mind
multi-streaming and the announcement just the announcement
stream so basically it's going to have all the details of
the tournament itself like who's participating the
tournament i haven't fully confirmed my team i'm the last
person to fully confirm my team because i had someone drop
out last minute today because they had like something else
going on during tournament day so i was like oh okay i gotta
find and i have to like i have to find someone like by the
end of today i have to find a replacement at the end of
today uh before before the announcement stream um so that's
like one thing that's stressing me out a little bit so i i
have to figure this out soon um other than that um the
tournament itself it's gonna be um we proposed this option
to them because i thought it'd be better for like visibility
and stuff because the obviously the pubg blind spot twitch
account might be like super new and stuff so there's not
like a lot of people following that so what we propose was
that, let me double check, is that I give them during the
tournament itself, I give them my Twitch account to, because
I don't know if they have it, I don't know if the PUBG, I
don't think it's the PUBG Battlegrounds Twitch that would
have been broadcasting it, they'll have to use the PUBG
Blindspot account, and basically, my Twitch account, they'll
have access to my twitch account during the tournament so
the main broadcast with the casters and everything and the
povs different povs will be on twitch will be on my twitch
during february 15th and 16th and then um on my youtube
stream will be my pov with my team so that's how it's gonna
be so the people on twitch can also do like a coach can also
do a co-stream um with the twitch broadcast too was i
thought it was a cool thing to do because you know they can
use uh you can they use my twitch stream to have like to
give more visibility for like the main broadcast lali thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you just want to say
i'm happy exist you bring lots of enjoyment to people's
lives thank you thank you thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i bought a lunchly today uh are you still
happy that i exist guys are you
Why?
Do I still...
Do I still bring you guys enjoyment in your lives?
Joke, do I tell you?
Can I refund my...
So, I saw a wild lunchly in the wild.
I saw, like, you know, a lunchly in the wild today.
And I was like, you know what?
I've never had a feastables before, you know?
I've never had a feastables or a...
Wait, I can...
Wait, let me bring it down right now, guys.
Let me... Let me bring it...
For my fridge.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna bring my lunch.
Lee.
Give me a sec, guys.
So I've never had a prime.
I've never had a feastable.
And I've never had mold on pizza before.
So let's try this out.
Let's.
Let's try.
Let's try this out.
So for those who don't know, But those who don't know, the,
uh, the, the, let's see controversy, um, because they say,
quote unquote, that they don't have any preservatives on...
Wait, where's my feastable?
Oh, oh my God, it's such a ton of chocolate.
Sorry, above average chocolate bar.
All right.
I got cherry freeze as my prime.
This is the first time... I'm getting cred right now.
It's my first time I've ever had prime.
before.
I've never had time.
I was like, oh my god, is that a lunch lead at my fucking
grocery store?
And it's the first time I've ever, because it's not like
fucking American, you know, so this is the first time I've
ever seen it in the wild.
I was like, oh my god, I get to be, you know what it's like
to be the 51st state.
It's just Gatorade.
This is, I'll eat a minute.
Holy shit, this is literally Gatorade.
This is, this is like, it's literally Gatorade.
I've had this exact flavor.
What do you expect?
Okay, it is pretty sweet.
Let me see what the...
It's 5 calories?
There is no way.
There...
What?
Okay.
It's 5 calories and the total sugar is 0 grams.
There's no fucking way I don't believe that.
This is really sweet.
Is it just all chemicals?
Maybe it's just chemicals.
Like, carbohydrate is 1%.
Five calories.
That's insane.
There's no way.
I feel like maybe it's just like...
Yeah, I feel like artificial sweeteners.
I think it's just all chemicals.
Spends all her money on Fortnite and that's to eat rations
to survive.
2026 color or high scale.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It has to be a lot.
All right.
Before I try to mold the pizza, I'm going to try my very
first Mr. Beast feastables.
My very first Mr. Beast feastables.
I hear people say it's chocolate is like, like doesn't have
a lot of chocolate taste, which is crazy to think about
because like it's fucking chocolate.
What the?
fuck how can a chocolate okay no they are right they're
really they're this like the chocolate is like you can tell
it like there's very little flavor for chocolate yeah it's
like it's like You know, like, it's really like this type of
chocolate where it's like, I guess it's like vegan chocolate
type deal where it doesn't have very, it doesn't taste that
milky or taste that chocolate type deal.
Yeah, it's very, it's like diet chocolate, yeah.
I feel like there's not a lot of cocoa on it.
What the fuck is this tomato packet?
It just looks like ketchup.
All right, I haven't had like a lunchable in a long ass time
in general.
Also, my favorite, I never, I never really liked the pizza
lunchables in general.
I think my favorite was the cracker ones.
It's all right.
It doesn't look moldy.
It, okay, that is, okay, I will say, like, what the fuck is
this?
The amount of cheese you get is like this tiny little
packet.
That's a tiny ass packet of cheese.
wouldn't hurt, right?
How do I open this?
Oh, it's over here.
Captain, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
It's all right.
If I don't stream tomorrow, you know what happened to me.
If I, if tomorrow I went missing, you know what happened.
This is like the, I basically documents in my downfall But I
use the cheat like I put like a bunch of sauce on one slice
and then I and then I put the rest on top of And I put it on
top of the others.
All right one pepperoni
Oh, yeah, that white was tomorrow too.
That's fucking that's karma for me
Okay I will say the tomato paste is not that bad.
The one thing that doesn't feel super cheap is the tomato
paste.
The tomato paste is not...
I would actually get the tomato paste up with right there.
I mean, I literally just gave billionaires more money.
I gave Logan Paul KS.
Okay, KS5?
Alright.
You know what's crazy?
it's like what ksi mr beast and logan palm but if you like
look at oh my god there's so much i get only three slices i
should have been drenching this in tomato sauce i did not
realize this is only three fucking slices look i i gave them
one one point damn they oh my god we just i've been like con
but look here's a point for the tomato paste and there's
like shill shill bird sponsored hashtag pr hashtag ad she
gave one point
how dare she but anyway i will say it's crazy to think about
but i think like i of all three of them you know ksi mr
beast and logan paul wow ksi is the lesser of the three
evils and you guys are like there's no way you compared you
think ksi is less evil than mr beast mr beast literally made
the hunger games like
he fucking he made his own hunger games like i don't like if
anything ksi if anything got rage made it on Twitter, but
Mr. Beast literally made his own hunger games.
Like, yeah.
Like, he's just, he has a cringy-ass song, and he made his,
he, he got rage-baited to hell on Twitter, but at least he
didn't make his own hunger games.
Like,
oh, that's true.
Bro, almost said Bro actually sent someone on fire.
What do you mean?
Almost.
He actually did it.
Bro, in the fucking...
You know what's great?
In the goddamn...
I didn't watch it, but I saw like...
I saw like tweets talking about it.
But like Mr. Beast literally buried a bunch of contestants.
Like in a cemetery.
To replicate his buried a live challenge.
And I'm like, bro, that's...
That's sociopathic, man.
that's so crazy that game let's today i'm gonna bury 50
contestants under the ground to see how if see how they feel
when they get buried alive
guys in this beast game you recreated it
also i will say i think it one of his
would you accept an invite to his fuck yeah i say all that a
lot but like i would still go join if i get an invite to
join to join the content creator beast games i will because
like because i can get one million dollars bro okay You guys
will actually pass up on a million dollars.
You guys, you guys sell it out.
Guys, it's a million dollars.
Guys, would you really pass on for a million?
It's like the guy that was like in the Beast Games.
Where for those who didn't watch the Beast Games, he was
like, um, no, I'll be, I'll do this thing where I send
someone to represent me.
send someone to represent me and i'll tape a monitor on his
chest i'll tape a monitor on it like no i'll tape a monitor
on his face and then or on his chest and then that's how
i'll pull it up i'd be like looking to hire like the most
athletic person in the like the perfect peak human human
person like conditioned person i think human person he has
to be human by the way And then, and then I'll send him as
a, I'll be like, oh, can I send this guy to represent as a
representative?
He's my cousin.
I'll be like, I'll be auditioning to be like the guy who
would let me tape a monitor on his chest.
And then I'll be like to Mr. Beast.
Oh yeah, this guy's my cousin.
He's family.
Can I have him represent me?
It's technically me.
yeah we'd have yeah and then okay anyway that reminded me of
that video I volunteer as a chance as like my champion to be
donkeys versus champion in the Mr. Beast death games but
like did anyone see the fucking crazy ass video like the
video of like the Mr. like on Twitter where during his new
beat his Beast game season 2 it was like to one of the the
contestants, I will give you a million dollars if you send
your team to the deaf ground.
And there was zero hesitation.
He pressed the button.
And like his team was like, how could you do this to us?
God will look down on you today.
And I'm just like, buddy, he doesn't even know who you guys
are.
You guys just met today.
A fucking course will fucking press the button.
That is so like a million dollars is a million dollars.
Why the fuck would he not press the button?
He's he doesn't know your life story he just met you today
yeah yeah it's a yeah why wouldn't you press the button fuck
yeah send them down there again no hesitation he just
pressed it instantly and then he's like i'm a million
dollars richer i don't care he's like and mr b's like how do
you feel knowing that you just set your team to to the to
the death round he's like well i'm just a million dollars
richer now
exactly they would have done the same fucking thing if they
were on his shoe i would have done it too i would have done
it i'll be like if i was like on this guy's team and he
pressed the button i'm like oh you know what that's fair i
don't just be like you know um that's fair yeah
narrow hesitation.
Hmm.
Exactly.
It's irresponsible to not press the buttons.
And Mr. Beast had to, like, try and be like, wow, I can't
believe you would do it.
I'm like, what the fuck anyone would do in this position?
What do you mean you can't believe he did it?
Alright.
My rating for the lunchly I will say the tomato paste was
actually pretty decent I had it okay I didn't tell you guys
this as well but I also bought a lunchable as a control
group earlier that is the only reason why is because like
the lunchable had a transformer on it too but I was just
like oh shit let's grab that one too I was like we had
lunchly I might as well First off, I saw the Lunchable first
Because I was like, oh, that's a Transformer, man I've had
Lunchable in a long time And then I saw the Lunchable I was
like, you know what, let's test this out No, the lead, it's
okay, I'm It's either lead poisoning or mold They'll fight
each other The lead poisoning will fight the mold And we'll
see who wins Anyway Anyway, so I also got the pizza one
Because that was the one that was on the Transformer Evil
Doki would be like, I don't want the money.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, they'll cancel each other out.
Anyway, so I think Lunche's tomato paste is better than the
Lunchable tomato paste.
The cheese, Lunchable gave me more cheese.
And also more slices, the pizza slices.
um i like the capri sun more than prime because i think
capri sun is also healthier than prime there is i there's no
way there's no sugar in prime that feels like a lot i like
drank prime and then i don't think it i there's i don't
really believe it's like mostly electrolytes um and i think
there is some some sugar in there i
Capri Sun wait how is it supposed to be pronounced that's
how my parents used to pronounce it so that's how I
pronounce it it's like how when I was growing up when I was
growing up and I had to sing the ABCs uh since my parents
were Asian immigrants in the Canada um English was their
second language so when they were teaching me the alphabet
it would be like a b c d e f c
G-H-I-J-K-L-O-M-N-O-N-O-N-O-N-N-O-N-N-O-N-N-N-N-O-N-N-N-O
because that's how my parents pronounced it so so so and
then you know the teacher was like all right students uh
let's sing the alphabet and then they're like and then i
would be like hello and then and then she did like she would
do like little quizzes on the alphabet too and was like guys
what letter um what what is the first letter for the word
lion and i would raise my hand And I'd be like, hello!
And then the teacher would be like, um, can you repeat that
little dokey?
And I'd be like, hello!
And then all the little kids laughed at me.
And then the teacher was like, oh, it's pronounced L.
and and now and that's why i have trust issues that's why
and then i remembered going home to my parents that day and
crying and brawling my eyes out and was like why did you lie
to me why did you teach me that Why did you teach me the
wrong letter?
It was never ELO.
It's ELO.
I trusted you.
I thought you knew the alphabet.
So, so yeah, it's like that.
So my parents will always be like, do you want a Capri Sun?
And now I find out it was never pronounced Capri Sun.
I don't even know what it's actually pronounced.
Guys, I don't even know what the real pronunciation is.
I've been living a lie for 20 plus years thinking it's
pronounced Capri Sun.
Anyway, source Ben, thank you for this super chat, thank
you, thank you.
All right.
I purposely taught her a ride as a joke.
My neighbor's super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Anyway,
that's my life.
I'm still drinking for...
I don't want to waste this pride.
It just tastes like Gatorade.
It tastes like Cherry Gatorade.
It tastes like Red Gatorade.
That's the word better word.
I used to drink a lot of Gatorade in middle school and high
school because I did a lot of sports.
So my mom would always get me electrolytes.
Or just buy me lots of...
I always drink a lot of electrolytes during my practices.
And this literally tastes like Red Gatorade.
Purim, thank you, thank you.
I was made fun of by a teacher in high school and from
everyone for pronouncing Capri-San.
Capri-San, just like you, thank you.
At least we can both suffer.
We can trauma bond together, Purim.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh.
Alright, let's check my super chats real quick.
Oh, and then super chat reading is so long.
Uh, do I even have that as a text?
Oh, I don't.
even have the text doing super chat reading right here uh
there you go it's donation reading time i have one that's
just for super chats or is it actually donation reading
about text yeah it's just donation reading uh jacardo think
of the super chat thing you think you i'm an asian parent i
sing slight speech impediment as a child so that alphabet
story is entirely relatable turkey life do be like that
sometimes thank you the super chat thank you thank you yeah
that's why it's why it's why i can't pronounce things i i
have like a uh i like second doubt myself when i pronounce
stuff of words that i've never heard before spoken before in
real life because it has happened way too many times where i
say a word and then and I realized it was never right I'd be
like that's not how I say it in my head like fucking
quesadillas goddamn quesadillas and and tequila it's not
tequila it was the one the the one that kept pronouncing it
and everybody got mad at me.
Like tortillas.
The tortillas?
Yeah.
I will pronounce the tortillas.
And you're like, you're not.
It's tortillas.
Spark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Found you from the Halo stream.
And you need to love the chaos.
It's my birthday in two days.
Can you get a happy birthday for my new Oshi?
Oh my God.
Spark take.
I hope you're still here.
Happy birthday.
sorry i was in a when i'm in a collab stream um i i like
sometimes i like don't have time to look at chat in time
because a conversation is going on so i'm really sorry spark
tech i hope you're still here but have happy birthday also i
think we were doing tech support too in the beginning we're
trying to figure out how to fucking start the lobby but if
you're not here anymore i do hope um you are watching at the
end of the vlog to get your little happy birthday um a happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear spark tank happy birthday to you yeah
happy birthday uh many bite-sized rice thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you many thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you your first super chat here oh you
weren't the first it was spark tank uh lord kurosus thank
you for the super chat thank you thank um i think i used to
pronounce it jala jalapeino i'm pretty sure i think like it
was like jalapeo or some shit i don't fucking remember i
knew it wasn't jalapeno though i i knew it wasn't because
i'd be like oh it starts with jake clearly it should be like
jalapeo or jalapeo pano jala pano or some shit yeah um and
so my cat thank you the super chat thank you thank you
collab stream dokey thank you i'm glad you had fun watching
thank you thank you thank you solid uh nexi johnny aka zoro
quill papa smear thank you for super chat thank you thank
you thank you mike thank you the super chat thank you thank
you dokey can read i know very surprising sometimes i even
surprise myself rice thank you the super chat thank you
thank you always happy to see a sloppy collab thank you the
super chat thank you thank you i'm glad i'm glad to organize
another slap i saw the yapp yapp game and i was like this is
the perfect game for sloppy sisters a side of Mimi fries
because it goes up to five people and the more people we
have the more we can make the company happy then more people
than company will be happy to farm more money from us uh
next seed thank you the super chat thank you thank you
thanks for organizing the collab today doki it was really
fun and all that talk about p was kind of nostalgic thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you lord kurosus
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you You got it
right, 100%.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see it.
What else did I miss?
Uh, Papa, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Also, Hon George, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I had a pipe burst in my house today.
So thanks for the three-hour distraction.
Just in time for the To tuvkey Day marriage.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God.
I hope your house is okay.
I've never had a pipe burst, but, um, um, I, I, I assume the
bill is like really, really high because that shit is must
be like not only does like, you know, you got to fix the
pipe But like everything else like the floors and everything
and like Like the floors and tiles and everything is wet as
well And then you have to like drain stuff too.
Yeah, that sounds like that this is why you live in an
apartment and not a house I would assume like a house is
just harder to upkeep versus an apartment because like an
apartment the building does like most of the run of like
does most of the what's the word the um the uh i guess the
checks the building checks and everything pipes can burst in
apartment too yeah but then the building has to pay for it
not me because it's on them and not me because how the did i
that up yeah maintenance yeah management the building does
the maintenance and the management of the of like the all
like all the the like all the rooms I guess so like because
of that yuppie about everything so because of that I don't
really have to worry about the maintenance stuff but I know
the house is nice and everything but then like I'm scared of
the long term of owning a house because like because I'm
like oh man That's a lot of things.
Lots of things to clean.
The upkeep and the lots of things to be aware of for the
upkeep and also the cleaning of a house.
And then you have to renovate it too.
It could be a small house.
I don't want to live in suburbia.
If I have to live anywhere, if I have a house and I have to
live somewhere, I want to live in the gated community.
gated communities are closer to the city and like I never
lived in a suburb I technically never lived in a suburbia
before because like in in Canada I've I've never lived in a
suburbia before because when I was growing up uh richbert no
my grandpa my grandpa was uh was rich and he and he lived I
told you guys I lived in the gay community when I was in
China with my grandpa and he lived next to next to an
amusement park I told you guys he left live next to an
amusement park so I always hear I always heard fireworks at
10 p.m and I hear the national anthem at 8 a.m.
so I'll be woken up by the national anthem and then I could
I cannot sleep after 10 p.m because the fireworks will be
going yeah yeah because the amusement part will play the
national anthem at 8 a.m every day and then also we'll have
fireworks every day at 10 p.m but but my grandpa it didn't
matter to him because he would be awake at like guys okay
remember this was before the joke was a thing but at 6 a.m
he would be awake at around 6 or 7 a.m because he goes
golfing um every day he would go golfing at the golf club i
told this story before um but um he was a golfer and at six
to seven a.m he would go golfing uh or he'll wake up early
have breakfast and then go golfing so it was like normal
hours for him um before he goes to work
yeah so that was like the one time i lived in a gated
community Um, and, but then when I was in Canada, when I was
in Canada, um, oh my god, okay, it's actually, okay, I'll
tell you, this is actually, I'll give you guys a little Lord
dump, um, uh, about, like, my extended, my family, I told
you guys, my grandpa also, like, married, uh, a new, a new
wife, um, after, like, my grandma died, like, so he got, I
got a step grandma, and she was, like, literally only, uh, a
couple of like two to three years older than my oldest uncle
um yeah so anyway so anyway before that when i was in canada
well i told this before i told this story before about my
step grandma but she really liked me because um when she
asked like me what i want to buy i was just like i want
books you know like i would ask for like inexpensive stuff
and then the other cousins would want like my other cousins
will ask for like brand name products like you know they
would want like like like designer brands like clothes or
bags or shoes and then when she asked me what i want i'd
just be like i want books i want some english books because
it's so hard to get english books here like because i didn't
care like for those who don't know in china um designer
brands um are much more popular over there than it is in
canada uh when i used to grow up so like in canada no one
really wears designer brands or any like you just want like
something comfy it'll always be like uh roots or gap or like
old navy like stuff like that like people don't really wear
designer brands in canada but in china is like a lot about
like like um like the image and stuff so like a lot of
people would get cars a lot of people get designer brands
and everything um so it was like a whole um what's the word
it's like a public look that you have to upkeep and stuff
yeah like it's like a public face that you have to have um
and so my grandma my step grandma liked me the most out of
all my cousins and then so my other cousins really fucking
hated me because i was like my grandpa and step grandma's
favorite because i didn't really care
I didn't really care about like designer brands or like
expensive items I cared about video games But then like you
couldn't at that time you couldn't really The only place you
can go to to get like Games and stuff like video games
either for your DS or like for your PlayStation or Xbox You
have to go to Hong Kong to get it because you couldn't get
it in China back then And or you go to the underground
market
My dad would take me to the underground market with the
boxes.
And then you, like, flip through the little plastic bags to
find.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the underground market.
Anyway, as I was saying, in Canada, in Canada, I also didn't
live in suburbia when I was growing up in Canada for the
first 10 years of my life.
it was technically not suburbia because if you go down the
street you will you you basically it's where like all the
stores and the restaurants were so like like technically it
was suburbia but not because just you go down like three
blocks and you're at the the street where all like the
restaurants and stores were so um like like near us so it
was like it was sort of like close very close to like a
place to go instead of like but then like i really hate
suburbia because um When I was in university, I was touring,
like, places to rent, you know, because I didn't want to
live with a roommate, I think, in my second year of
university.
So I didn't want to live with a roommate on campus because
I, like, first year trying to live with a roommate was
fucking hell.
My roommate was, like, the party girl, and I was the study
girl.
and literally she was like inviting people all the time into
our dorm and I fucking hated it and then because like and
then every time someone would be knocking on my door to like
to like ask for her and I had to make a little sign where it
says if she was in the room or not because I kept getting
people when I'm studying because I was taking like seven
classes for a semester because I wanted to graduate early so
I took like like at least seven classes um for like the
first year of my semester per semester yeah basically each
semester I had seven classes um seven or eight I don't
remember I just had like a like the maximum amount um yeah I
hated myself I really did um so that's why I was like
spending a lot of time just studying and stuff and because I
wanted to graduate early um because i already did the
international baccalaureate i already did the international
baccalaureate and i think yeah and um so i was on the path i
already had like almost a year's worth of credits from the
international baccalaureate program so i was like oh if i do
all these classes i can graduate like like half a year or a
year earlier um if i just churn it out on the first year and
and then i did not want to do the ib program by the way my
parents you know what's up i'm sorry i'm jumping between
tangents but in high school the ib pro when i was about to
hit uh 11th grade when i was about to go to like my was it
was it junior year 11th grade um my school what like my
school got rid of the ib program Because they're like, it's
too hard.
So my school got rid of it.
And then my parents were like, how dare you get rid of it?
We're transferring her to another school where it has the IB
program.
And so they took me out of my school that have all my
friends in.
Took me to a different city that had the IB program in.
And then I had to start.
junior year with people i've never like like zero friends
and like zero friends new city um all the other classmates
have been together since like kindergarten and and also uh
three weeks but at like three weeks late into the school
year by the way so like i to the school three weeks late so
so I was already like I was three weeks behind in the first
semester of junior year it was so traumatic and I usually I
would like use sports as a way to distress but they had they
had no female soccer team they had no female volleyball team
they had no female basketball team the only female team they
had was handball and then i remembered this like after my
first year during my after like end of the year for the
theme during the end of the year my junior year because i
didn't join handball because i was like that's not a fucking
real sport i'm sorry if anyone actually plays handball
that's not a fucking real sport but all the guys had actual
teams and then the only team I could join in that school was
literally track and field and the field department because I
was like the best at shot put because I did shot put javelin
discus for my old school so that was like I automatically
got it because I there was no competition in that new school
there was no fucking competition in the new school for the
field department so I got into the field team for discus
shot put and javelin for them but that was literally like
the only sport I did for that school because all the only
teams they had um the only teams they had in that school was
was for the guys and not for like the females so I was just
like what the do I do like and then I had to play I played
volleyball with the teachers at that school because the
teachers had every lunchtime, they would have like a
volleyball, like I guess like a pick-me-up game at lunchtime
with all the teachers there and the assistants.
So I just joined in because they're like, wow, the student
actually knows how to play volleyball.
And I just played with them because I had nothing else to
fucking do.
And I was like craving any type of sport.
Like I was just like, this is so fucked up.
Like I was craving any type of sport that I can do.
Like, and I was like, Anyway, anyway, anyway, so funny
story.
At the end of my junior year, we had to play handball
because it was like end of the year.
And they're like, okay, guys, what do you want to play?
And then like my class, like my PE class was like, let's
play handball.
And I was literally fucking destroying everyone because I
had good hand eye coordination.
And then the PE teacher, who was apparently the coach of the
handball team, literally pulled me aside and I was like,
wait, why didn't you try out for the handball team?
We might, we were looking for someone like you.
And then I straight up told her, I don't see handball as a
sport.
Like,
I'm sorry, I don't see handball as a sport.
Like, yeah, to her face.
To her face, I just, I was like, I'm not trying out for your
fucking handball team, ma'am.
I'm sorry.
Like, I don't recognize that as a real sport game.
Because I felt like I was playing, it's literally for those
who never played handball before.
This was also, by the way, the very first time I played
handball.
And it was literally, it's literally like, it's literally,
you catch the ball.
When you catch the ball, you can't move with the ball.
So you can intercept the ball.
It's just not a real fucking sport.
I'm so sorry.
It's like the only time you can move is when you catch it.
And when you catch it, you just stop.
And then you're supposed to shoot it into a goal.
It's an Olympic sport.
I'm sorry.
Like it was like a pity.
I swear to God.
Handball got in and be a pity.
I'm sorry.
like it's just passing the ball that's how I feel like
you're you're just passing the ball like it's not like I'm
sorry and then like there's a goalkeeper in the goal that's
just I
um anyway any I I'm it looks very it it I personally think
i'm sorry it just looks very stupid i'm sorry compared to
the other sports i've played i i just i just don't recognize
it it's like how people are like i don't recognize sealand
as a country i don't recognize handball as a real sport um
um well i think it was richard thinking thank you and now
you're a vtuber i know know anyway and then and i don't
remember how the teacher reacted i just went back to playing
handball i just went back to the class like after she pulled
me aside i just and i told her i don't remember what i said
after i just remember saying i'm sorry i don't see handball
as a sport and then i it's a real sport and then i just i
kept playing
and then okay anyway i want to tell you about this other
story um then you guys were like well if your grandpa was um
was so wealthy like what happened like after he passed away
you must have been willed a lot of money no because um
because like um my i have one uncle one aunt two aunts and
one side and um they were all very money hungry people as
well i don't care i'm there i'm i'm you know what's crazy
after my grandpa passed away we've never seen my extended
family again like because like the only reason we were all
together was because of my grandpa so that was the only
reason why we would all meet up together so like it was for
like my grandpa like and it's classic soap opera
it was literally like the classic soap opera where like you
know like those TV dramas those TV dramas where like all the
family members are like trying to vie for my grandpa's
attention and like because he's like the head chairman like
the head the head of the family and everything and yeah so
um so my My aunt, my two aunt, like, I would say, okay, one
of my aunts was actually adopted.
It was actually a really, um, a really, it was like a
semi-sad story, but my grandma, my actual grandma, not my
step grandma, my grandma's brother, um, wife couldn't have
children, like, was told that she couldn't have children.
So my grandma adopted a child for them.
And then later on, like, she got the...
her brother's wife got pregnant so they're like we don't
need her as anymore so like and then my my grandma took her
back in and raised her as her own um so like so my one my
aunts was adopted um and but like it was only my grandma
that like recognized her as like part of the family and but
then she did grow up with like the rest of my like you know
my aunts and uncles and is a crazy story but she was like
she always helped out the family a lot and she would be like
the one to take care of like my other aunts and my other
uncles kids as well um and she has her own she has her own
family as well too uh because my grandpa helped hook up my
aunt uh my aunt with like um with like a husband and
everything like she like apparently the the aunt's husband
um the husband was like the top of his class like he was a
government official um and he scored the highest in his
class and everything to get into the government and stuff um
so my grandpa helped my adopted aunt uh arranged like
arranged the uh the date for like you know like a what's it
called a blind like not blind date like arranged a date
between the two for them and stuff yeah number one rank of
his class and everything anyway so yeah so you know so then
like obviously like the husband helped out with my helped up
like with my grandpa as well because you know he obviously
is like i told you it's like a tv drama and shit so like
that my grandpa could also like you know use my adopted
aunt's husband to help with like um with the with any like
with any jobs that he needs to get done because he was a
very smart man anyway yeah it's like he helped with the
matchmaking yeah anyway my aunt my other aunt and my my aunt
that's crazy okay my other aunt i'll tell you her story she
got divorced got divorced but yet the husband was always in
the picture somehow like it was so weird it was so fucking
weird he would always show up and then start got married to
another guy and then got divorced with him and then came
went back to the first husband is like it was so weird it
was so weird
yeah like yeah like
And then my other uncle was a fucking playboy, just like
those TV dramas, because he was the firstborn son.
It's always, you know, like the head of the family, the
firstborn son is always a playboy type deal in those TV
dramas.
That was literally my extended family.
The firstborn son of the head of the family was a fucking
playboy for the majority of his life until he finally
settled down.
with like a beauty pageant winner with like like a beauty
pageant winner um yeah and uh she was really pretty i will
say like his wife was super pretty um i remember when i
first saw and i was like whoa oh yeah he was also divorced
too i forgot about that because like when they got married i
was I didn't really visit the fab I didn't really I think I
don't know if I was born yet but he also like cheated on his
like on his first wife a lot so then um and then but then
like she got like super ostracized because like back then it
was like you don't talk about it like you just got to suck
it up back then like because it's like all about your image
and everything so nobody really gets divorces and stuff back
in the day especially if you're like you know for the
reputation of the family like i told you it was a tv drama
because i was like why because when my mom was telling me
the story of the first wife because i was like there was a
first wife and she's like yeah we don't really talk about it
much but um back in the day like he cheated on her a lot and
she would always come to me when she's crying about like new
girl he was with and you're like but like she had to suck
like at first she had to suck it up and just like let it
happen because for the image of the family you're not
supposed to get a divorce or anything because it looks
really so like she sucked it up until it was too late and
then like she was like because like and then she stayed
because she was like if i have a kid with him it'll be it'll
be okay and in the end they never had kids together so then
she was like i can't do this anymore i'm gonna get a divorce
and then she got super ostracized from the family and then i
like to the point where i didn't even know she existed like
i didn't even know he had a first wife that i didn't even
know like she even like existed like when I was finally like
there like yeah yeah and it yeah and then yeah and then like
so yeah and then my oldest uncle he finally settled down um
and it was fine it was like now he lives in like Portugal
like because he was like he was like I want my kid to um to
be like to have like be bilingual and then I was like
Portugal yeah they now live apparently I was it was one of
the European countries because he was trying to like he was
trying to like immigrate to a foreign country and he was
trying really hard he look he I remembered the story because
he kept asking my family for help because kidding I was born
in Canada um I was born in Canada and um but my parents were
immigrants and he was trying to get my dad and my mom to
help him immigrate immigrants immigrate somewhere and he got
his applications got rejected like from to a lot of
countries and I think like the only finally he got accepted
and it was Portugal like he was trying like trying so
because he wanted his son to have like to be like more like
i guess more international and and stuff so he wanted his
son to be more international and have more life experiences
he was like 10 at that i think he was like 8 or 7 when he
was finally when he finally went to portugal um but um
portugal was the one that fought because i think he wanted
to immigrate immigrant immigrate to australia um but then
his application and I think he tried Australia, Canada, and
in several European countries and then finally in Portugal
was the one that accepted him and then he moved to Portugal.
Bandit, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
It's my birthday and I gotta support my Kamioshi who got me
into VTubers.
Thank you for everything you did, Joki.
Thank you for this Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you have a great birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear bandit.
Yeah, happy birthday.
I don't know.
I don't remember how many countries he's applied to.
I remember, like, when he got rejected to Australia, he was
crying and calling my dad about it because he was like, you
know, he wanted help with it.
And then my dad was like, I can't get too involved into this
because the thing is, the reason why, was because like, um,
it's harder because a lot of my extended family has
government jobs in, um, has government jobs.
So it's harder to immigrate to other countries because of
it, uh, because of my family, my extended family background
history, uh, working in the government.
So it's a lot harder.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Look, my dad never, never worked in the government.
That's why he's able to immigrate to Canada with my mom.
Because my mom immigrated to Canada when she was a teenager.
Anyway, more background lore history.
Yeah, I'm a double H.
I'm a sleeper agent here to collect your data.
I'm actually a sleeper agent right now.
Anyway.
Don't joke, it is getting the sleeper face.
La, la, la, la, la, la, yabadabadoo.
Anyway.
Okay.
The original story I went to, I want to talk about was that,
um, oh yeah, and also I really, I never liked my extended
family because, like I said, they were all, like, super
money hungry and power hungry.
Um, and I was just, I, I, and they hated me because my
grandpa and my step-grandma really liked me.
Um, they said I was, like, the best grandchild out of all
the grandchildren.
So, obviously, I was also the smartest grandchildren, like,
grandchild out of all of them.
So, and the only one that knew English as well.
So my cousins and my extended family hated me because of it,
because I knew English.
I could speak English, and I had a lot of, like, awards and
stuff, and I was doing well academically as well.
And, um, and so, like, and I was technically the firstborn
that, that, although I wasn't a son, I was the firstborn,
but I was the firstborn that had my...
my grandpa's last name so I was higher tiered than the
firstborn grandchild because the firstborn grandchild came
from my aunt's side so his last name was the husband's name
and not my grandpa's name um and then obviously my uncle my
uncle ended up having the firstborn son but my grandpa and
grandma always compared him to me because they would be like
when Doki was your She was, she already won this, this award
and that award.
And she, um, and she was always reading her books.
Uh, your, but your son, she's out there playing on his iPad,
playing, playing video games, um, at the dinner table.
But when Doki was his age, she was reading her books at the
dinner table.
Why can't you be more like Doki?
And then here I am sitting at the dinner table, reading my
book as I hear this argument going on for the seventh time.
no oh no yeah i'm just like oh no
yeah yeah and then like my grandpa and grandma would always
like do these comparisons to my so all the cut my cousins
ostracized me because they were like they're like fuck her
like she thinks she's so special just because she knows
english and ignores us whenever we try to talk to her but
thing is i didn't know mandarin at that time because i grew
up with cantonese um i hate youtube and i was on george they
get the super chat they get they so then my cousins hated me
um because and also like my like you know um because they're
like the golden grandchild and then getting like she's
always ignoring us doesn't even want to hang out with us but
at that time i could only speak english and cantonese
because i've never learned mandarin because my parents were
like she doesn't need to know mandarin we just talked to her
in cantonese like but the rest of my the all the other all
my cousins spoke mandarin and it was only my uncles and
aunts that spoke cantonese because they didn't teach their
kids cantonese so they didn't teach their kids cantonese and
my parents didn't teach me Mandarin so I couldn't I didn't I
had to it took me like a year or two to finally understand
Mandarin by then it was too late and then the cousins hated
me because they're like oh she's she doesn't give a fuck she
thinks she's so good she thinks she's better than us yeah
she doesn't she pretends she pretends she ignores us all the
time pretends to don't understand us and I was like I don't
know I'm pretending I actually don't even know what you're
saying because like they would try to talk to me they would
try to talk to me and I would look at my mom and I or I
would and be like, what are they saying?
I see like, they'd be like, and I'd look at my mom or dad to
be like, translation, please, because I don't know what
they're saying.
I don't, they're like, and I'm like,
oh, oh, oh.
I was so confused.
yes my parents were mic translator while I was growing up it
took me a while because I um it took me a while because like
like I said like Mandarin Cantonese at that time I've never
heard Mandarin before because like in Canada everybody spoke
Cantonese and I was in a Cantonese um um my school was a uh
English slash Cantonese school it was like a a Catholic
private school um but and they had like after school
Cantonese program there so we would all just speak Cantonese
so I've never heard Mandarin before I didn't realize there
was a second dialect because my parents never spoke Mandarin
to me before either um in Canada so so when I came to China
was the very first time I heard Mandarin and then at that
time I was like to me it was like a different language and
it took me a while to like like like immerse myself into
like you know in the language um to to figure out because
then by that I watched a lot of like Chinese TV and also
like honestly listening to conversations and stuff to the
point where I finally understood like the difference between
the two and then like I finally figured it like you know it
took me like a year I think like a year to finally like be
able to like listen to Mandarin and to be able to like what
they tell me but I couldn't really speak Mandarin too yet
but it took me like two more years to be able to speak a bit
uh but i had a really bad accent when i tried to speak
manner in it was it was like it's like super ex-accented um
anyway anyway um the end goal of the story where i was
saying like after my grandpa passed away like i have no more
connection with my extended family it was because he passed
away when i was in canada and my parents were also in canada
and then when he passed away and that we were they were
planning for all the families were planned like like like
Senate family was planning um the funeral the uncle called
us and was like we need to talk about the will like to like
be like you gotta give us um they're like trying to
negotiate the will because like apparently um he didn't will
he didn't I don't know what it was but um my grandpa didn't
finish the will so because of that there was like a
negotiation regarding like who gets what
who gets what and then my dad he is the youngest child he is
yeah he is like the youngest child of the entire family so
because of that um My dad didn't want to get involved in the
family drama after my grandpa passed away and was just like,
just don't involve me.
Like, I don't care.
So we didn't get anything in the end.
We didn't get anything in the end because like he didn't
want to get involved with the whole negotiation of like who
gets what and like of everything.
split it even though you know that in the perfect world
maybe but this is my tv drama right now this
this was my family tv drama and i never works that easily
yeah yeah yeah and and so i like my family didn't get
anything in the end when my grandpa passed away um so i
didn't inherit i didn't inherit anything at all um uh oh
yeah also like it was crazy because like all my cousins were
trying to fast pass life getting like getting a kid getting
a wife getting a kid so that my grandpa could fund
everything that was how much i like i hated my extended
family because like my oldest cousin the technically
firstborn married uh got girlfriend early married super
young um had a kid super young um and like uh begged my
grandpa for a job at his company like so he could like and
then would just follow him around everywhere um so he could
like get as much money as he could.
Yeah, so like he literally begged my grandpa for like two
cars.
My oldest cousin, he got two cars.
And then and like a loan for his kid.
And then my grandpa paid for his wedding and everything.
Yeah.
So he like fast passed as much as he could so that he could
like mooch off of my grandpa as much as he can for his
future.
Yeah.
And then he tried to take my my oldest cousin tried to take
my family's car because when we moved to Hong Kong we had a
car in China and then you called up my dad and was like oh
you're not using that car anyway like can I use can I borrow
it uh since it's just sitting in the garage and then my dad
was like what the fuck no like why do you want my car you
already have two cars like yeah and he would always because
like I live with my grandpa when I was growing up um uh when
I was living in China I lived with my grandpa growing up so
my grandpa would always host like family dinners and stuff
like every Friday there would be a big there would be a
family dinner with all my extended family my uncles my aunts
um and cousins and everything like every Friday or Saturday
but on the other days I would always eat with him like my
family and I would always eat with him because we would one
of the reasons why we came back to China was because my dad
wanted to take care of was the caretaker of technical he
wasn't like caretaker he just wants to um take care of my
grandpa like you know take care of his dad um because the
other family members didn't do it so my dad was like the
caretaker uh for like my my like his dad so we would live um
we would like uh live with my
And so, but then, like, when my oldest cousin, when my
oldest cousin got a job at my grandpa's company, he would
always follow us around everywhere for free meals, for free
dinners.
And it was so awkward, because he was obviously there for,
like, free food and everything.
like he didn't like he would be like don't worry i'll be the
i'll because like my grandpa also has his own chauffeur and
everything he would have his own chauffeur and stuff and
then my oldest cousin like told told him to let go of his
his usual like his usual chauffeur that he's always had for
years and he's like don't worry i can drive you around and
so he could like follow like so he could like mush off of
the dinners and stuff and that's also why i didn't really
like my cousin like my oldest cousin um oh yeah and i didn't
like my other cousin because he made me do his english
homework when i went to hang out with him fuck that guy like
when i first came to when i first came came over uh when i
first um came over to china uh moved over to china and my
mom wanted me to make friends with my cousins um one of my
cousins invited me over and i thought we're gonna have like
we're gonna play or something like because it was my first
was the same cousin that gave me food poisoning because his
stuff like he told me to eat like street sausages because
he's like it's fine they're really good and i was like okay
and i got food poisoning and he was okay because and my mom
scolded me and he was like he's like dokey you're so stupid
like he was born here his stomach is made for these types of
food you're not you grew up in canada you're not fit for
this food yet your stomach is weak and i was just like and
then i was you know fucking dying of food poisoning I was
dying like I don't have local resistance yeah I wasn't made
for it I was like I didn't know my cousin said it was really
good anyway other than that he would fucking make me do his
English homework because he'd be like well I can't play
right now so um you'd be like I can't play right now because
I have to do my English homework I guess if you want to help
me finish my homework then we can play together So he would
force me to, because then, like, if I don't, I just don't
know what to do, because I was just, I had to stay at his
place for, like, half of the day until it was dinner time,
and then we go meet up for the family dinner thing, and then
so, like, because then he would, like, it's not, it was
either I wait for him, I would wait, like, a couple of hours
for him to finish his English homework, or I finish it for
him, so we could do something, or else I have nothing to do,
because I was like, what the fuck do I do, I don't know, I
just moved here, I don't know what to do, And then so he
would make me do his stupid English homework And then he
would scold, yeah And then he apparently almost failed his
English homework Because I didn't fucking know they were
teaching British English So when I was like, I saw a soccer
ball I wrote soccer And then he was like, you, he was like,
you did this on purpose You gave me the wrong answer The
right answer was football And I was like, what the fuck is
football?
I was like, that's not football.
A football is a diamond ball.
That's a circle.
That's soccer.
He was like, the right answer was football.
And I was like, bro, I don't fucking know what football is.
The only football I know is American football.
Like, and then he was, mad because I almost made him failed
his English homework because I was fucking I was doing it by
like you know you know I was doing it by like the fucking
English I grew up in that's like the one one of the things I
remember because you got really mad at it he's got because
the next time came over you got really mad at me being like
you almost made me fail English not fail english but you
almost made me like fail my english homework and i was like
this is the right answer i was like it's the right answer i
don't fucking know why it was marked wrong
i gotta pee real quick i'll be right back guys
all right i'm back oh yeah also i just remember okay uh pun
flair uh swordsman papa Nexi, Nepers, WB, Solid, Medi, Rice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
There's another reason why I was trying to fast pass into
graduating university early.
It was because my grandpa at that time he was like, whenever
you graduate, I'll buy you a house.
And I was like, and I never asked for anything.
I never asked for anything in my life, like, from my
grandpa.
So I was, like, free house.
But then, sadly, my grandpa passed away before I graduated.
So I, I, I didn't get the free house.
That's why I don't have a free house.
I didn't.
Yeah.
It was like, because he was like, you want to, okay, it was
crazy, like, when I got my driver's license, he asked me if
I wanted a free car, and I was like, no, it's okay, I don't
want to drive, I was just like, I don't want to drive, I was
so scared of driving, and I was like, it's okay, I don't
need a free car, I didn't, so he's like, okay, how about
this, because I, I got my driver's license, uh, when, When I
turn 18, when I turn 18, because I got my drivers license in
Canada.
After I graduated high school, I went back to Canada to get
my driver's license because I graduated high school in Asia.
And then I also really hated driving.
So I was like, it's such a waste of money to get me a car
because I really hated driving.
like after after I passed my driver's license um after I
like I did first try by the way my parents and my fucking
driving teacher never believed in me in getting my driver's
license on the first try they were so surprised like I came
back and I was like I pat I got a hundred percent and then
they were like oh they actually were like cheering and
celebrating and then my driver's teacher was like are you
like even my driver's teacher did not believe in me getting
passing it on the first Like, my parents also.
And they're like, you're not joking, right?
I was like, no, I got it.
I passed my test.
And they were like, and they're like, we didn't think you
could do it.
And I literally got 100% on my driver's test, too, by the
way.
I had, I took lessons every fucking day.
And even then, my teacher or my parents did not believe in
me getting it on the first try.
And, and.
anyway and then after I got my driver's license I never
drove a car since um like I never drove a car since so like
when my grandpa was like congratulations on driving your
driver's license do you want to I can get you a car and I
was like no it's a waste of money like I don't want it I
don't want to drive it's such a waste and you're like how
about this um after you graduate university I'll get you a
um I'll get you a I'll buy you a house slash apartment
because at that point time I was like I like an apartment
please and not a house because I was like what am I fucking
am I gonna do like because like you know like I just got in
university and I was like what the fuck am I gonna do with a
house after I graduate I was like I'll be like I'm by myself
and then I also have to take care of like I'm like I need to
figure out what the fuck I want to do in my life and I was
like I I don't think I am like suitable in in owning a house
yet so I like an apartment is cool too you know yeah yeah I
was just like an apartment is cool too because I just got
into university so I was just like thinking about it I was
just like that has so much work like and I don't even know
if I want to live there for the rest of my life with a house
I don't know um yeah I was gonna say I'm so young how do I
cannot manage a house so young right now I feel like i need
to be older to be able to manage a house i don't even know
how to manage a dorm room um how much did your grandfather
pay that the sorry they give us a super chat thank you thank
you yeah and then but then unfortunately my grandpa passed
away before i could graduate university so like and then my
parent like i didn't inherit anything um from my grandpa
grandfather uh because my like he didn't finish his will um
he didn't finish his will um for this like like it's very it
was very sad when that happened but it was also like um i i
personally don't know what happened um but i think like he
he got he had like a test or something like he got a scan
and they found something and he did surgery but i don't
think it i i like i just heard bits and pieces of it from
when my parents were talking because like they didn't want
to tell me the whole story so i only heard like bits and
pieces of what happened um and then like i think like after
uh after the surge like apparently the surgery wasn't
successful um in removing whatever it was that he had and
then he passed away uh uh he passed away after that so i
unfortunately i don't know the full story of what happened
but that was like thing is the really fucked up part was I
never even got to go to the funeral um because like my dad
didn't want to be involved um with didn't want to be
involved with like the family dynamics after him passing
away and like the family politics that was going on that we
didn't leave Canada uh and went back we didn't go back to
China um when he passed away during like the whole funeral
and everything so I never even got to go to the funeral
which I was really sad about because he didn't want to get
involved with like the negotiation of like because like they
were saying if you're coming to the funeral we have to talk
about like what we're doing with like his assets and
everything yeah so I never got a chance to go to the funeral
because of it which is one of the things I regret the most
because, uh, he's been a big part of my life.
And despite the TV drama, I had to go through.
Yeah.
Despite the, um, no, I never got a chance.
I never went back to, I never went back to Shinjin after
that.
Uh, because, um, after that.
So I, I don't even know what happened because like my entire
family my my close my family cut off the extended family and
then i don't really like i said i don't talk to my parents
anymore um uh and my parents are separated now so like uh i
don't even i don't even know what's going on anymore like so
i don't going on anymore so i i don't know like where my
like the details of like where my grandfather like when was
buried or anything yeah yeah like i told you my family is
like it was it was very like those tv dramas that you see uh
that you see uh like actual soap opera shit
yeah yeah But I'm, I, that's why I think I'm saying, I, I'm
doing as okay as I can, learning how to be on my own, like,
I'm trying my best, it's like baby steps, you know, it's
like little baby steps every day.
The Doki lore is insane, yeah, but it was, like, my choice
to not, to, like, leave my family, also, like, not like, you
know, I'm expended.
extended family was my family's choice for extended family
it was like my family's choice to cut off the extended
family because they didn't want to get involved in uh they
didn't want to get involved in like the family politics
after my grandpa passed away and then for me it was also
because like my uh my parents were very controlling um even
when i was growing up and it was like not very good
mentally.
And then it took a really big decision for me to finally cut
them out because like it was really bad.
Like it got really, really bad.
And then before all of that happened, my dad separated with
my mom before.
And then like, and it was like me and my mom.
And then my mom got very, very controlling because it was
just us two left.
because my dad, when he separated my mom, he flew back to
China.
So, and then it was just me and my mom in Canada.
And then it got really bad because she tried to control my
business and my life because, you know, there was like
nothing else left.
And then at that point, I was like, I had to make a big
decision and be like, I can't do this anymore.
Like, I am going on my own, you know, like I'm like, I'm
going to, I'm going to be my own person.
person and then I like cut myself off from there and then
found myself and and then left my and then uh found myself
my own apartment my my staff actually helped me a lot as
well and I found myself my own like my staff helped me find
an apartment and I literally moved there in a week and I
really appreciate my landlord for like like he literally
fast passed my application and everything and like got me
like let me like get the apartment and like rent the
apartment within like a week process and everything um and
and then after that like you know i've just been learning
how to live on my own type deal because i've always had to i
was babied a lot growing up and i was i lived in a very
bubbled how it lived in a bubble child i was literally a
bubble child i was like i said that's why i was like when i
was growing up i wasn't allowed to touch the stove or
anything until I turned 18, which is fucking crazy.
Like when I told people that, they're like, are you okay?
And I was like, my parents never let me touch the stove.
Like, like I wasn't allowed to touch the lighters.
I wasn't allowed to touch the stove or anything.
And like, I didn't learn how to use the dishwasher or like
use the, like use the laundromats or like, not the laundry,
the dryer, the washer until I was like 18 and then that's
when my parents had to do like a fucking because they're
like they're like oh shit you gotta because I chose the
university I chose was not the university they wanted me to
go because the university they wanted me to go was a more
Asian university and I went to a predominantly white
university instead because in their heads gonna they were
gonna try and uh they were like oh okay if she goes to the
university here we have a lot of relatives and friends that
live there and then we can hire one of them to like look
after her so she doesn't have to learn like basic
necessities and then i was like nope i'm gonna choose this
university instead i'm just like i want to choose this
university instead and that like through in their plans
because they're like oh okay we got we got teacher we gotta
teach her everything
it's so because i was like um i don't know how to do
anything
and and then so they had to do give me like a like what is
it called like a speed run lesson on life on how to use the
washer, use the dryer, learn how to cook, learn how to use
the stove.
And I was just like, ooh, what?
They're like, you gotta do this and this and this.
Yeah, crash course on everything.
The whole speed run before I went to university, before I
went to a dorm.
um rice thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
moving away from my parents was one of the best things i did
for myself i'm glad you got out of the situation thank you
thank you thank you thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you yeah it was one of the hardest decisions in my
life but i don't regret it at all because um i get to be my
own person now instead of like it's hard being it is hard
though there is a lot of difficulties i am a lot more
stressed out but i have more freedom to actually do what i
want to do instead of having my life be controlled by
someone else which is something it got really bad like um i
can talk about this really because I've like I guess like it
was a long time ago so like I've what's the word I've like
processed it and I guess like um and like be able to like
move from it but like it was like bad to the point where
like um like basically I didn't even have control of my own
bank account type situation So like, like my parents
basically controlled my entire bank account and like I
didn't have access to my own bank account too.
Or like my own or like basic stuff like they would put my
name on like they would put my name on things that I can't
even use and stuff.
my dad got a car but then he put my name on it and I don't I
don't even know where the car is anymore because when I left
like I I didn't I couldn't get the car like the car was in
my name but like it was not my car yeah yeah yeah so so I I
don't know where that car is I don't know what I
yeah and yeah and i was just like we're i don't know i just
like i the my first thought was like i just want to move out
you know that was my first thought like i was like i want to
move out and i want to you know i want to have i have to
like you know i want to get out get all my stuff that i can
get out get get and keep and then and And then, you know, I
had, like, one day to fully move out, basically.
I had to, like, speed run to move out.
Well, the thing is, my dad, at that time, when I fully left,
it was just me and my mom.
And then my dad, my dad at that time was already separated
from my mom.
So it was just me and my mom left.
So, like, it was just, like, my mom had the use of the car.
type yeah and it's just like stuff like that and then like
they would like use like they would take money out of my
bank account i this was a long time ago people during like
the bark knights era remembered that but there was one time
where they took money out of my personal bank account to
like buy a car and like that shit fucked me up a lot when i
was growing up because i saved a my personal bank account
and then like they were like we're gonna use your money to
buy a car it's very good for your credit and then i was just
like but i'm not even gonna use that car like this was years
ago though this was like this was like a couple of years ago
yeah and then and then but they're like don't worry like uh
it'll be really good for your credit and then and we're
gonna need you to go over there to sign the car in your name
and i was just like i don't need a car i just i i i don't
drive but then it was like my parents car type deal yeah and
that's like basically like how bad it was so like that's why
like when i was finally like when i was finally like you
know my own person and everything I just the freedom it gave
me was just more more worth it than like the struggles of
trying to learn how to be a person like how to be an adult
yeah yeah I was just like I was just like um and then
obviously without your help chat I wouldn't be all of that
because i was never i never had the courage or like the
financial i guess like the financial security to even do it
because at that point you know i heavily depended on my
parents and stuff on like life and stuff because like at
that time i didn't really have like a job that paid enough
to be my own like to be independent so like i relied heavily
on i couldn't like like I had to like just you know follow
along and like listen to my parents and stuff with like
whatever they want me to do and everything and be like you
gotta do this you gotta do that and like even when I was
like you know even with the whole family politics back then
uh with my extended family I was also like it was like also
like super controlling where they're like you gotta do this
you gotta do that you have to do this you have to do that
like you gotta you know
I gotta have a tutor every fucking day.
You know, it was wild in high school.
I had a tutor almost every day for every subject to make
sure I do well in school.
And each tutor session was like two hours long every day.
And I was like, it was fucking terrible.
It was so, like I had like, in the eye, especially like in
the, it was like during my last two years of school, I had a
tutor every day.
for all the subjects I was taking to make sure I don't fail
my international baccalaureate.
It was two hours every fucking day for each subject.
Sometimes I would have double sessions.
So I would have a four-hour tutor session.
So it would be like a two hours on math and a two hours in
biology or something for one day.
And then the other day would just be like, it was like, it
was that.
And then like, obviously there was like family image at the
uphold back then.
and like, oh my gosh, I hated the, I hated the big family
dinners sometimes, but it wasn't like every day, like
sometimes they were fine, but then like, it was like every
Friday or Saturday, I had to come to the, I had to come to
the big family dinner and like be like a model
granddaughter, and like my mom wouldn't let me play video
games too.
Sometimes I wanted to play on my DS and And I, like, you
know, I would be playing Pokemon Mystery Dungeon or some
shit.
And then my mom would be like, yo, here's the book.
Read the book.
And I'd be like, I want to play Pokemon Mystery Dungeon.
I, I'd be like, I don't want to play Pokemon Mystery
Dungeon.
Like, no, no, read your book at the dinner table.
you're like not fair i just want to play pokemon mystery
dungeon i just let me play pokemon like
and i have to remember everybody's names and everything and
be like remember oh my god and they're like remember the
greetings and then remember everybody's family name like all
like the and stuff like that like oh um like like because
uncle is like papa and bat learn right is that that that's
how learn is papa and papa is like uncle and then uh gulma
is like is like auntie right and then it was like bap bap
learn gulma gujun uh and then yeah and then like but then it
and had to remember like the aunties and uncles aunties and
uncles parents as well so like the wives or husbands
grandparents that they also brought along and I have to like
I have to greet everybody too when I go to the fake family
dinners every Friday and Saturday I have to go up to every
single my mom would bring me up to every single one of them
and say hi to them like like I entered I it's like they
would they would book the uh they would book the family
dinner at like it would be like private rooms and stuff it
would be like these big private rooms at like the
restaurants and stuff and then every Friday and Saturday
when we have our big family dinner we go in I have to go up
to every single one of my relatives and their grand like the
like the plus the grandparents they brought and then be like
I will have to greet every single one of them and have to do
like a formal greeting for every single one of them every
Friday and Saturday and and and then and then like um and
then after ask me about my studies and stuff like that and
then my mom would feed me lines to say and be like tell them
about like the award you just won tell them about what
you're learning today like tell them about the sport you're
doing right now and how good you're doing and i'll just be
like it's like you know like a puppet and i was just like oh
i fucking hated it i hate it that time
yeah it was like it was so much fucking pressure back then
it was so exhausting and like I do some of the things I do
miss a lot is yeah you know like that when we were playing
yapp yapp and then I was like the little monkey dancing for
men when she turned me into a tiny like when she turned me
into like a tiny guy and then I was just like woo dance
monkey dance yeah I think it's like no it was just like very
it's it's not your typical controlling or strict it was just
that my extended family had a really like had a image to
uphold so like the politics within it like I said it was
like literally it felt like a TV Like that you watch on like
the Chinese TV like not just Chinese the Asian TV dramas
That you actually watch on TV about like the head of the
family and like their their his like sons and daughters and
stuff And it's like the corporate.
Oh my god.
It's it literally felt like I'm reading this web comic right
now called What is it called?
There's this Korean web comic.
I'm reading right now and I'm like heavily related to it I
was like, oh my god, let me pull it up.
I've been reading a lot of webcomics webcomics, the webtoons
lately.
I love the Korean webtoons.
They're so good.
But it felt like, if you guys ever read Reborn Rich, that's
basically, in terms of, like, the family corporate dynamics
and stuff, that's sort of how like, you, it's like, you can
really trust your extended family-type deal.
It's called Reborn Rich, and it's like, it felt like, it's
how, like, you can't really trust your extended family
because there's always like a hidden motive to like
everything they're doing and that was so fucking exhausting
it was so exhausting in that family it's a really it's very
it's a really good webtoon i highly recommend it because it
teaches you a lot
it teaches you a lot about it but i really do appreciate
like everyone's i think without this career like the path i
went with and then without my dragoons you guys your support
um and everything i wouldn't be able to like i guess like
branch off from that dynamic and be able to be my own person
type deal i really appreciate it guys like it really does
mean a lot because like i said your support and like this
community I wouldn't be able to like I guess be independent
for the first time and like like fully fully independent for
the first time and just be my own person because like
majority of my life was there it was like mostly just be
doing whatever like whatever my parents or like my extended
family wanted and like I can just be me now which is really
nice I like that like even in university the degree I went
for was just to benefit my family I didn't get to really
study the thing I really want I mean I didn't even know what
I wanted to study to be fair I won't say what I studied in
um but um what I ended up double majoring I did major and
minor, but what I went for my major and minor was for what
my, was for the benefit of my family slash extended family,
because I went in there being like, oh, um, this can help my
grandpa a lot.
And then like, I, or like this can help my family and
extended family a lot going into it.
And I didn't really know what I wanted to study.
So I was just like, I'll just study this because this will
help my family.
Like,
yeah so i didn't even know like i don't even know what i
actually would have wanted to study because i just did
whatever my parents slash extended family what what would
benefit my family slash extended family the most i will say
i didn't do medicine i was not smart i almost failed math
guys i was not smart enough i i i liked biology but like
because i was so bad at math i didn't like my brain just
couldn't wrap the concept behind numbers like i couldn't
wrap my head around numbers like i don't know why i just my
brain was never i think i i was i'm just good at yapping
like that's my special gift yapping and being funny what's
up thank you the super chat thank you thank you and then
once you're in it be like you don't know how to do shit
thank you super chat thank you thank you solid thank you the
super chat thank you thank you extremely proud of you silly
bird truly glad to be your silly dragon thank you thank you
thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you thank
you i mean it's in the least pair show show way possible i
think a lot of us wish we could offer you a hug or something
right now thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank
you guys thank you the super chat thank you thank you and
now you pass on the trauma in the clovering club jokes like
side good that you feel comfortable enough to talk about in
public talking about these things help a lot here's my
therapy fee thank you for that super chat thank you thank
you yay i trauma i'm sorry i was like and that is my trauma
dump for the day i do
yippee thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you wait a minute wait a minute She's just trauma
dumped for free.
Wait, we just paid for trauma dump.
That's right.
I get free therapy and you paid for a trauma dump session.
Next scene, thank you.
It's with a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so proud of you for everything you got managed to move
past and how well you've done on your own.
So glad that we're supporting you and becoming your own
person.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
thank you like i feel more comfortable talking about this
now because it's like i've been my own person for like how
many years like almost two years now um almost two years now
like living on my own so i feel more comfortable talking
about it now um especially because like i've been in contact
with um any of my family um an extended family for a bit so
i feel more comfortable
of like moved on from it and accepted it and typed and it's
like progress um right thank you super chatting thank you i
was here where once a year vulnerable doki yay you were here
for this now i'm gonna close the gates now close the heart
close my heart and i have maximum security i've vaulted it
it's like the the when you when Disney vaults a movie or
some shit and then it would be like back into the Disney
vault you go until the platinum released we've been
bamboozled dragons okay thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you shows over no more vulnerability that that
isn't what Kratos would want feelings are Pussies guys.
What will Kratos think?
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Headpot, emote when we need it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maybe like next month, I should...
I'll message an emote artist for it.
You guys gotta figure out which emote you're voting off the
island, though.
It's time for the annual Doki Bird Emote's Hunger Games or
Survivor.
Which emote will you vote off the island?
um let's see sim thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you thank you thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you thank you thank you um oh see thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you the umineko fans in chat
curious if your family has a private island and is haunted
by a blind witch thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you oh my god What is it called, like the...
Um...
I want to say, I want to let you guys know, I'm not a
secret, what's it called, the Che, Che, Chebun?
The, you know, like the Korean socialites, um, like the
Korean, um, The mega ultra rich.
What is it called?
What's the word for them?
They have like a special name I will say I'm not What is it
called?
Che...
Is it Che...
Cheba?
I don't know how to pronounce it.
I always see it in my web tunes.
Che...
Chebas?
Okay.
Renunciation.
Cheba?
Is that how you pronounce it?
How to pronounce it correctly.
I'm looking through.
I am looking...
I'm looking, watching the video.
Cheba.
Oh, yeah.
I am not a Cheba.
For those who are wondering.
That's pretty suspicious, Joki.
I am not like a Chinese equivalent of a Cheba.
For those who are wondering, we were not that level.
We were not at that level, guys.
We were not.
That's what they all say.
that's what a chamber say like those that's what i read in
my webtoons where they fake and pretend to be a regular
person and then like those like the that's what that's what
they say in the romance team romance mawan tv dramas where
the guy or the girl is a secretly a chamber and they're
chasing after a regular person so they have to pretend to be
a regular person so that they they don't they don't want the
other guy to take advantage of the fact that they are a
Yeah, and then they run into a poor person and then they
fall in love.
Yeah.
That sounds real.
That's literally, that's literally like 90% of the Korean
webtoons, Korean webtoons and romance TV dramas where one
guy is secretly a Cheba.
A Cheba is basically, basically like, so in Korea, they are
like large, so a lot of like very big businesses in Korea
are mostly like family-owned conglomerates, so they would
have a monopoly on specific businesses, and they're known as
the Chebos.
So they are like the top of the top of the top in society in
Korea.
and uh a lot of the families because it's all family owned
too like it only they only pass it down uh to their family
and stuff it's always like in the family everything yeah
it's like the top oligarchs and um and uh the the the
children in there are like basically like everything is
planned for them in terms of like who they married what
their life is gonna be like publicly wise A lot of them is
like arrange marriages, uh, arrange marriages with other
chapels.
So they want to marry other chapels so they can merge, like,
uh, so they can have, like, access to each other's, like
companies and stuff like that.
Um, and it's like, I will say, I will say, uh, my fat, my, I
am not the Chinese equivalent of a chapel.
And we were never at that level.
For those who were wondering, we were never at that level,
guys.
That would, like, I feel like if I was a Cheba, or, like, I
don't know what it's called, like, the Chinese equivalent of
that.
Guys, I swear to God, I feel like if I was, like, the
Chinese equivalent of a Cheba, like, I would have got docked
so quickly.
Like, I would have been, like, what was it?
uh aliexpress's uh granddaughter actually a vtuber yeah i
like my whole life would have been revealed so easily like
probably you know yeah literally my time like like there
would be so much publicity being like yeah this rich this
like oligarch family grand the granddaughter is working as a
vtuber
oh yeah team what I think the Chinese equivalent is uh let's
see what is it called uh I actually don't know what what the
Chinese equivalent of that is because like Chepo is just
such such a popular genre
kai tune where is that that.
Is that what it's called?
It might be Kytune.
Kytune.
Yeah.
This VTuber is daughter of what the granddaughter of which
Cogomerant Company.
Yoki married and divorced me so I could take half of your
stuff.
I didn't inherit anything.
My bank account is literally everything I've made in my
VTuber career.
Guys.
Guys, my bank account was really really bad before i became
a vtuber i just need you guys to know that like
it was i didn't even inherit anything guys everything i my
bank account is literally only money i made in my vtuber
career yeah i explicitly never i didn't inherit anything at
all like
I am self-made
Lolly, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
gotta say I didn't expect to talk about this much about it
than you ever have in this fucking yapp-yapp stream of all
things, it's because like I never get to do super chat
reading or just saxodon streams no more because I'm always
so busy but then like today it was a very short stream and I
was like, I haven't had chance to talk to you guys in so
long.
So I was just like, it's, it's trauma dumped.
I haven't talked to my dragoons in so long.
In a one-to-one session, it's time to trauma dump.
It's Lord Kroesus.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
We love you, dokie.
The dragoons are lucky that I've noticed you.
It's wonderful to use and we are thankful you're here every
day.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
I think that's why like, like that's why I don't run ads and
why I try my best to I don't want to like milk you guys you
know like that I don't know how else to say it like you know
like run spam ads and everything I just want to have a good
experience with everybody because like for me I just want to
make enough money so that I can so that I can like do the
things I want to do like do have like a good And like, I
don't care about being like a like super duper fucking rich
or whatever.
Or like trying to like make as much money as possible.
I just want to like make enough so that I can live
comfortably.
I can live comfortably and like be able to do fun things for
you guys.
And so being able to like be able to do all these projects,
all these fun events and stuff.
And be creative in my streams.
have a good viewing experience because like I don't care
about ad money in general.
I just want to like because running ads doesn't give people
a good viewing experience.
I want everyone to have a good viewing experience and I
don't care about like trying to like I'm not sure you're the
Logan Paul shit you know like you know like that type of
content creation where he literally is all he's doing is
just trying to make as much money as possible and as fast as
you can.
That's why don't take like you know i don't like people are
like i try not to take like um sponsors that are like you
know like you know that's why i also don't want to take
gambling sponsors and stuff like that um and everything
because i i like i don't view gambling i don't view gambling
sponsors ethically as well and stuff and um and you know i
don't want to have a good experience i just not here to try
to make as much money as possible as fast as I can.
I just want to have a fun career.
I want to have a fun career and make lots of fun memories.
And then also, and then also like be able to live like, come
like just, you know, comfortably.
Now I don't want a mansion or anything.
Like I don't fucking care about designer brands or shit.
Like I'd barely buy clothes for myself.
Um, this is also, okay.
This is also an example why I don't really care much about
clothes or shoes and stuff anymore because my mom basically
couldn't like controlled like what I wore and stuff like
that to like I wouldn't care what I wear in general but then
um if I don't you know during like some family dinners and
stuff like I have to wear like like specific clothes to be
like to look nice and I had to own specific designer brands
to like and I'll be like I just want to wear a gap.
I just, I just want to wear a hoodie.
I just want to wear a hoodie and sweatpants or like, I don't
want to wear, I don't care about handbags.
I don't care as long as it's comfortable.
I don't fucking care.
Like, because that's why I grew up in Canada.
And then when I had to, when I moved to China, when my
extended and like see my extended family, when I do the big
family dinners, like always have to wear whatever like my
mom wanted me to wear so like she would buy my clothes and
everything um and stuff like that because like for me
whenever I want to whatever I personally bought clothes I
just look at it I don't even go to I have changing room
trauma because like I hate changing rooms and stuff like
that um I hate changing rooms because like when I was
growing up um my parents would make me do like a one hour
changing room show where I would always have to I, you know,
they, my mom would pick all the clothes she wants me to try
on.
I go in the changing room, have to come up, model it for my
mom.
She makes me turn around all the time, like turn this way,
turn around, look left, look right, turn around, go back,
change your room, try this shirt with this pants on.
Then I tried this pants with this shirt on.
And then, and then it was like almost like an hour of that
in just the changing room.
And, and like, and it's why I never.
use the changing room anymore because like i know what i
want to buy and then i know my size i don't need to see what
i look in the changing room if it doesn't fit i'll just
return it i don't care like
like i i don't care if i don't if it doesn't fit and it
doesn't look good i'll just return it whatever um yeah and
and then it's like so like for me like even when i'm like I
barely buy new clothes I barely buy I barely if ever I never
bought designer stuff for myself like all my designer brands
when I was growing up was bought by my parents or my
grandparents um and then when but like it wasn't the oh I
the only time I bought a designer shoe that I bought for
myself was the YXL sneakers because I was in New York City
and I won't really it was just like it was one the shoe that
actually caught my eye and it I really really fucking wanted
because it was so pretty and that was like one time I
actually bought a designer shoe for myself and wasn't bought
that wasn't picked by my mom or my grandparents yeah and
then um and then it's like and then but like now nowadays I
just I don't really buy like whenever like I just wear
hoodies like I buy my pants and my clothes like my clothes I
buy it at artist alley now.
I don't really care that much about like fashion that much.
Like I buy my clothes at artist alley because I really love
like the stuff that artists make because they're all like
either artist alley or like what are those like not like
they're like markets little art artisan markets.
Is that what they're called?
It's not like it's like those like artisan markets where
like a lot of like people who Um, made their like allowed
like indie, like small business owners and small business
owners or like indie artists make their own clothes and
stuff.
So I would just go to artisan markets or, uh, or, uh, artist
alley to buy like clothes or like like sweats, like, you
know, pants or like, hoodies and stuff and shirts and stuff
because they're really pretty.
I think are like, you know, I'm supporting local artists.
I'm supporting small artists and small business owners.
And I think their products are really pretty and the quality
is really high.
And then for pants, I just buy it at Uniqlo or Old Navy.
Like, or Lulu Lemon.
I will say the only time I splurged by myself for pants is
Lulu Lemon.
Because those yoga pants are fucking fine.
They know how to make good yoga pants They know Like they're
fucking expensive But that shit is Fire I love Lululemon My
My My Male friends always Are like always shit talking
Lululemon I'm like you don't understand you're not a woman
That shit is comfy That shit is That shit is fucking comfy
as hell like you don't understand you not women you don't
understand how good they are like
um anyway but but i go to uniqlo uh old navy or or lulu
lemon for pants i i would agree my parents did introduce me
to Lululemon and that they you know they that was a good
introduction because because that that pants is those pants
their pants are fire and they're comfy uh they're expensive
but they're nice and comfy many thank you the super chat
thing thank you dokyo and poor place marrying me then you
was super chat thank you thank you papa smurf thank you was
a super chat thank you thank you my vtuber oh she is a chain
ball thank you the super chat that's I'm like I don't like I
that's why I personally find it weird when I see like um a
lot of content creators flex their wealth by spending money
on like those super ultra expensive brands because it's like
like I don't know like for me I'm just like oh yes like I
don't know how much money that is and I'm like oh man I
better just buy something else you know like I just like,
it's like, you know, my extended family would just, you
know, buy stuff like that, but I always feel like it was, I
don't know, I'm just like, man, I already said, I don't
know, I don't know, I get, like, I just like think about my
extended family, and I'm like, ah, man, I rather, I don't
know, I rather just spend it on something else, like, or, or
like, like, on Fortnite skins, you know, or, like, being the
Duchess of Ceylon, because that's just, I don't know, that's
just, that's at least funny, content having designer brands
isn't fun content it's just people judging you like yeah
yeah but but like as i hope fortnite i hope fortnite lives
forever so i can will my skins to my to my children or
grandchildren i was like and and to you my son or daughter
you get my fortnite
dollars by then i swear yeah yeah
i'd be like i will i will i would most definitely will my
fortnite account to someone because that shit that shit
would be worth so much money you know you know i hope it
better fortnite better live on to another another another um
i don't a hundred years that's right no another a thousand
years because that's right my my brain will be downloaded
into the pc by then no yeah that's my holy grail yeah my
holy grail account i'll be like like it's like oh my god
yeah it's like to you my son or daughter you get my steam
account with over 200 games and 150 of them i've never
played before because I bought too many games and I said I
will play later because it was on sell either on humble
bundle or on steam now it's your turn to actually play all
those games I bought because I was like whoa it's so cheap
and then I never touched them and it ain't that ain't that
the truth it is your job to finish what I couldn't the real
steam library just 150 in my warehouse of dog shirts and and
you must also finally sell the remaining dog shirts continue
my legacy forward thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you pass down your y'all virtual shoes oh my god my
kicks my virtual kicks on fortnite
now i mean thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you fatal thank you the super chat thank you thank you
just a suggestion you probably run an ad whenever you go on
a bathroom break i've seen others do that in your works
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i think
whenever you run an ad people will just click away and
that's because like you know people would rather have like
an afk screen than like something like because you can't
control what ad plays and it's such it like breaks the
immersion too which i don't like because i've had that
happen before where they're like oh i'm gonna go i gotta go
i'm gonna go queue another game i go to a bathroom and it
runs an ad and i'm like i'm gonna click away now because
they're like all right just have like i was just like afk
then just have because i can't control what the fuck ads
what ads are playing what if it's a really shitty ad i can't
control that and oh my god i can't believe in yapping for
five almost five hours now i need to find my final uh my
final teammate for the um pubg tournament so i got a message
a bunch of people giving us so anyway guys as always
everybody stay hydrated pause check get up move around get
that blood flowing and you say it for me and to bet cause
you deserve it i had a great time yapping you guys in again
it's been a long time since we had our own little Zatzadan.
It's been a very long time.
Today I felt very open today.
I guess I felt like I always feel very comfortable with my
dragoons and you know um there was an insane lord dump for
all of you guys today um but I had really fun talking to all
my dragoons and I had a really fun time just hanging out
with you guys and hanging out with sloppy sisters in Nini
and anyway guys I will see you tomorrow for more God of War.
Let's go it's back baby God of War is back.
Okay, guys.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.